the fist collides with Humphrey's face
crumpling him to the ground like a cheap
greasy Burger King rapper he feels the
lingering sting of the punch on his skin
and in the marrow of his cheekbone the
man who punched him a tall muscular
handsome man will refer to as Chad
stands above him with his fist still
clenched according to Chad Humphrey
Bingham the pale doughy 43-year-old
lying on the ground with a bruise
forming on his cheek had been
inappropriate hitting on his girlfriend
she told him to deal with the situation
and he had with one definitive bark to
leave his beloved alone Chad turns and
walks away leaving Humphrey on the
ground his face and pride equally
bruised a few hours later Humphrey is
sitting alone in a train car rattling
down the tracks in the direction of his
depressing bachelor's apartment he's
shaking with rage people they're
disgusting creatures really he thinks to
himself worthless animals that are
capable of nothing but cruelty and
exclusion they always let him down
always hurt him always made fun of him
every day getting up to face loneliness
and isolation felt like being attacked
by a pack of wild dogs one thought Rings
loud and clear in his mind it'd be best
if someone had the guts to just wipe out
the human race no even more than that
annihilate all life in existence wipe
clean the slate and salt the Earth so
that somebody or something more worthy
could grow that was the Fate everyone
else deserve for making his 43 years on
this Earth so miserable but beneath all
that there is another thought that's
making him smile he's got a plan a plan
that nobody else knows about a plan to
make everyone pay for every time they've
crossed Humphrey Bingham Humphrey you
see has an interesting job he works at
an infectious disease laboratory fans of
apocalyptic fiction are probably putting
together the picture already maybe he's
going to leak an infectious pathogen or
even worse combine and engineer multiple
pathogens together in order to make the
super virus capable of bringing Humanity
to its knees but that's where you would
be wrong Humphrey does have a vial in
his coat containing traces of the
Bubonic plague but his intentions with
it are actually far are weirder soon
enough he arrives home and secretes
himself away in his Bleak little
apartment it is a drab and gray place
except of course for his weapons bizarre
and impossible blades iridescent like
oil slicks in a crazed rainbow of
variety Blades of all shapes and sizes
from daggers to switch blades to axes
that technically weren't legal to own
you see Humphrey Bingham is what we know
as a mul Ninja a slang term for someone
who buys cheap and impractical
decorative weapons for display around
their home but the pride of his
collection has to be the apocalyptic
death metal sword as he's dubed it it
sits on a stand in the middle of all the
others bright purple and covered in so
many sharp edges it's almost impossible
to hold he has been refining and
perfecting it for years in some places
the edges are a single atom thin giving
them inconceivable cutting power and
when we say that he has been perfecting
it we don't just mean sharpening and
polishing littered around the room are
different volumes on the occult
particularly those concerned with
enchanting objects he's been conducting
spells and rituals grinding up desert
locust shells and illegally purchased
human bones and saying incantations he's
drawn all the proper pentagrams and
tonight he's obtained the decisive
ingredient he needs to make his plans a
reality the Bubonic plague sample saying
the complex incomprehensible words of a
spell he memorized Humphrey Bingham
produces the vial and carefully pours it
across the apocalyptic death metal sword
it glows and tingles radiating with pure
power and Humphrey finds himself
giggling with uncontrollable Glee he
imagines scenes from The Book of
Revelation his favorite part of the New
Testament where Satan Rises and the war
between him and God destroys and later
remakes the Earth he imagines his mighty
sword as an agent of almost Heavenly
power dealing brutal judgment on the
evil and the weak back in reality
Humphrey's insane dream might just be
coming true but in an even grander
manner than he'd imagined the
apocalyptic death metal sword floats off
of its stand but it isn't alone three
other smaller swords from his collection
also rise up the weapons that had been
practiced for all of his experiments it
seems they'd been a success a terrible
rousing success but Umphrey's dreams
quickly turn into a nightmare as the
enchanted swords begin to fight each
other but it isn't some free-for-all
Battle Royale all the smaller swords are
teaming up against the apocalyptic death
metal sword and the smaller swords are
losing as the wildly flailing death
sword slashes them into tiny fragments
of metal it is an act of rampant stide
and Humphrey can only stare on in horror
though the Rampage is nowhere near over
when the lesser of the swords are no
more the apocalyptic death metal sword
flails insanely as though battling
invisible monsters already it's far
beyond Humphrey bingham's control but
there is a method to this madness a
method that Humphrey himself is
literally unable to see the apocalyptic
death metal sword is so dedicated to the
Grand Mission of destroying life that
even bacteria cannot Escape its
stainless steel wrath on a microscopic
level every swing cleanly Cuts one of
the microscopic life forms in half this
terrifying weapon truly does not plan on
letting any of its potential victims
Escape up to and including the
unfortunate Humphrey Bingham himself
before he's even had time to scream and
run the sword turns on him it flies in
his Direction at Mock four speed and
unleashes an impossible flurry of
slashes by the time it's done there's
literally nothing left not even blood
just an empty room full of broken swords
where the creator of this apocalyptic
weapon has been cleaved into Oblivion on
the atomic level but the sword is not
done it slashes through the door and
heads out into the wider World ready to
pursue its Deadly Mission it isn't long
until researchers at a local Foundation
containment site catch wind of something
strange going on in the city they
intercept some frantic police chatter
about officers fighting off a sword no
not a person holding a sword just a
sword rather than just assume it's some
kind of strange police incident like the
time those two on duty cops avoided
investigating a robbery to get a Snorlax
on Pokémon go the site director quickly
dispatches a heavily armed mobile task
force on the scene it is a complete
bloodbath officers and civilians lay
dead in the streets as the sword
continues to fly around at impossible
speed what had initially been several
squad cars worth of responding officers
had been reduced to a mere handful full
of scared stragglers what they've seen
today would completely rewrite their
understanding of reality even if it
wasn't actively murdering their
co-workers and trying to murder them too
in the brief periods where the
apocalyptic death metal sword is in
cutting down cops and civilians it is
continuing to flail madly through the
air slicing more insects and microscopic
beings seemingly nothing can stop its
Rampage and that's when the mobile task
force helicopter arrives along with two
ground units in armored tactical
vehicles for support it's the kind of
precautions you can expect when the SCP
Foundation isn't entirely sure what
they're up against and little do they
know they're going to need all of them
if they want any hope of surviving and
defeating the apocalyptic death metal
sword but they're going to lose a lot of
good men before then MTF Troopers start
repelling down from the helicopter
wielding Advanced tactical assault
rifles they're able to lock on to the
Diabolical Maul Ninja Blade and fire
hitting it with a hail of armor-piercing
bullets but those bullets resoundingly
fail to pierce whatever anomalous armor
maintains the apocalyptic death metal
sword's structural Integrity the bullets
ricochet off making sounds like popcorn
kernels rattling around in a tin can the
blades counter offensive would be a lot
more effective it locks on to the most
dangerous Target first perhaps out of
pure bad luck on the part of the MTF
squads the helicopter pilot the sword
flies for him faster than he could
possibly move his vehicle out of its
path it skewers the cockpit traveling
straight through his chest and out the
other side of the helicopter the vehicle
consequently spins out and explodes
torpedoing its burning carcass down onto
the street below things are starting to
get interesting as the other operatives
pile out of the ground vehicles and
start firing on the flash of deadly
purple steel the massacre continues the
sword fing through Foundation Tactical
armor like Plato their bullets can't
harm the device or even really slow it
down a frightening thought passes
through the minds of one of the
operatives if this thing is left
unchecked for long enough it could
blossom into an XK Class end of the
world scenario there is no follow-up
thought though because the sword passed
through his mind moments afterwards
leaving him cold and dead on the ground
as the battle rages on Victory clearly
on the side of the apocalyptic death
metal sword the egg heads back at the
nearest Foundation containment site are
screaming to think up of a contingency
plan an entity wielding a weapon is
easily enough to kill or at least
disable but a weapon without an entity
that still keeps on attacking feels
almost impossible they're desperately
trying to collect information about the
anomalous item from the field but
anytime one of the operatives is able to
radio back they're killed by the sword
before they can impart any useful
information all that's left to try is
the nuclear option
thankfully not literally when
conventional teams fail they have
certain experimental mobile task forces
namely mobile task force Omega 7
Pandora's Box and one particular member
of that team who has expertise in that
area s SCP
076-2
AEL The Immortal Warrior years before
the incident of mass killing that would
cause the team to be disbanded while the
apocalyptic death metal sword did its
thing the rest of the team was was being
dispatched to fetch Abel out of Cold
Storage the second that this terrifying
tattooed Warrior is told that he'll be
up against another blade he's chomping
at the bit he's dragged into a
high-speed helicopter and taken to the
scene as quickly as possible fitted with
an earpiece so he can tell exactly what
he learns about the apocalyptic death
metal sword over to Mission command Abel
agreed on the condition that he could go
all out on his enemy for once his
handlers didn't mind granting him that
permission
after all nobody was even really sure if
it was possible to hurt an enemy like
this about an hour into the Rampage Abel
arrives touching down on the concrete so
hard that it buckles beneath his feet he
sees the sword floating there hideous
and garish even by his standards is his
opponent invisible it doesn't matter
he'll slay them all the same he produces
two of his obsidian swords and charges
in as the sword seems to notice his
presence and flies towards him at
incredible speeds it takes his truly
superlative reflexes along with his
considerable strength to Parry the
weapon at the decisive minute before it
can pierce his wretched heart it's so
much faster than he expected he's almost
impressed the blade does not wait it
circles and Strikes him again as he
deflects and Strikes at it with his own
swords and then something impossible
happens his swords break this hideous
purple blade has sliced clean through
them causing them to fall onto the floor
in multiple black pieces this is
impossible how could this blade have
bested his own over his earpiece his
handlers ask him for information on the
blade anything they can use able says
that the weapon doesn't make sense it
has the quality of mere steel but it was
somehow unbreakable that is all the
handlers need to hear they begin
immediately putting their contingency
measures into place they just need able
to buy them a little more time will he
be able to give the apocalyptic death
metal sword a good enough fight the
battle is strangely one of the toughest
he's ever faced his opponent feels no
pain no fear it doesn't even think or
feel it attacks and kills on pure
Instinct every time he pulls out a new
weapon an axe a sword a Warhammer a
chainsaw it's already upon Him slashing
away with unimaginable speed and
ferocity it mat es his own as every
Parry is met with a perfect counter
Parry he's now getting to grips with the
fact that his opponent is in holding a
weapon his opponent is a weapon but he
still refuses to let this be an easy
fight he summons a huge obsidian
broadsword from the space between spaces
and lunges in clashing blades with the
edges of the apocalyptic death metal
sword he feels its strength and its
speed its desire to deal death to
everything it was p here it was glorious
when the foundation reinforcements
arrive Abel is dead don't worry he'll
get better with the apocalyptic death
metal sword sticking out of his chest
after finding out that the sword is made
of steel the foundation operatives were
able to devise a powerful electromagnet
one capable of getting this unruly
weapon of mass destruction under some
semblance of control with the sword
ena's body retrieved this supernatural
weapon now labeled SCP 749 is placed
inside a vacuum chamber completely
sterilized in that scenario the weapon
simply shook around on the floor a
shadow of its terrifying former self
without even bacteria to destroy it can
only turn on itself and lay there in the
dark another dangerous anomaly secured
contained and soon to be protected a
textbook case for the foundation's
central Mission these days SCP 3749 sits
inside a fitted hermetically sealed
chamber full of kinetic gel designed to
suppress its constant urge to slash and
stab any and all life if ever that seal
is broken we just hope you're nearby or
in the very brief period you'll still be
alive you may learn firsthand what it
feels like to be sushi in that regard
the miserable Legacy of Humphrey Bingham
is unlike the man himself alive and well
Legend tows of many ancient weapons many
of them imbued with great power hammers
that call forth the very forces of the
heavens themselves raining down
devastating thunderstorms and
electrifying bolts of lightning to
Vanquish any foe or there's the
Arthurian myth of a blade buried deep in
the heart of a stone to any ordinary
person the sword is unmovable it won't
budge no matter how much force is
exerted on it or how physically strong
the person trying to pull it is only if
one of purest heart and truest virtue
should ever reach for its Hilt then the
sword Will Spring free and Grant the
holder the rightful rule over the land
but there is another weapon another
sword bestowed with a power as old as
time itself some have heard tales that
it was forged of pure Shadow by a demon
seeking dominion over all creation other
stories will claim the blade itself is
alive and capable of bonding itself to a
host while it grants its Wilder the
means to fell an entire army with a
swing of its Blade the weapon also
curses those who seek to covet its
destructive power slowly destroying them
the longer they possess this Unholy
sword such a powerful tool of
Devastation would bring chaos on this
world and any other but
this well this is not that sort at all
actually the weapon in question even
though it technically doesn't count as
one isn't some magical item in fact its
only real power is causing all of its
various owners over the years to end up
needing a serious trip to the ER so this
is SCP
572 okay sorry I'll do the voice again
but this is the last time or as the
Legends call it the katana of apparent
invincible ability now just like the
ancient weapons of Legend This Katana
has changed hands a number of times over
the course of human history one of those
to wield its completely uncredible power
was Jonathan a young man with high hopes
of going viral online as a master
Swordsmen however While most would only
ever gain that title after years worth
of study practicing complex hand-to-hand
combat forms and learning to respect the
blade itself and the craftsmanship used
in making one Jonathan just read a Wiki
how tutorial on sword tricks and
deciding they looked easy enough decided
that he could just wing it of course the
first step in becoming a master
swordsman without putting in any of the
work was to find an actual sword to use
and luckily the pawn shop in Jonathan's
Hometown had the very answer to his low
effort dreams hanging there behind the
counter displayed on the top shelf with
a thin layer of dust coating it was the
katana of apparent invincibility the
store's owner had long since forgotten
it was even there and was happy enough
to Mark the price down for the sake of
getting rid of it the moment he held it
in his hands Jonathan felt Unstoppable
like he could conquer his whole town
with the power of this mighty sword that
was barely sharp enough to cut wet
toilet paper he knew it would only take
one show of the weapon's very arguable
might to cement him as one of History's
Greatest Swordsmen unfortunately the
stunt that Jonathan attempted went about
as well as you expect naturally an
elaborate stunt involving a blunt Katana
and Jonathan's friend kie on a BMX bike
was sure to be a perfectly safe
combination any sane human being would
tell you that right after setting up his
phone at the skate park and hitting
record Jonathan called for collie to
ride down on one side of the halfpipe
and up the other while he used his
Newfound sword skills to cleave the
front wheel of her bike clean off in
midair having been promised a
replacement bike paid for by all the
hits this video would get online cie
went down then up then straight back
down Jonathan swung the blade only for
it to get lodged in the wheel spokes
bringing his friend and the solid frame
of her bike crashing down on top of him
in a heap of Tangled Limbs and metal all
the while nearby skaters filmed the mess
on their phones the ones who could hold
back their laughs anyway sometime after
the skate park debacle as CP 572 would
end up in the hands of yet another
wouldbe swordsman with just as
impressive impressive results Martin
zeilberger yes that is his real name had
grown into quite a controversial figure
over the years garnering his own Legend
of sorts although not a reputation that
any mythical Warrior of old would ever
want you see Martin had founded a
website that had in its earlier days
introduced the internet to a brand new
way of communicating and keeping in
touch with their friends and family and
as a result he had accumulated a
staggering amount of cash to show for it
but running a social media app didn't
keep the lights on forever despite his
company growing into a multi-million
dollar Corporation the market had become
saturated more new and Innovative sites
run by Martin's competitors began
appearing each new one more unique than
his had ever been back in the early days
keeping up and still making money was
hard so Martin resorted to Gathering the
personal data of millions of users his
site had amassed over the years and
selling that information to well anyone
who would pay him understand people were
a little upset to hear that all their
private information was being shared
around so brazenly that's when rumors of
Martin's interesting Behavior started to
be made public by some of his former
employees the internet had already been
Rife with jokes at Martin's expense his
stunted manner of speaking strange
barbecuing live streams filmed in front
of what looked like a green screen along
with many other quirks were often the
subject of ridicule some even speculated
that he was a collector of various
things a robot an alien even an iguana
and pretending to be a human being then
there was his choice of office equipment
specifically a certain Katana of
apparent invincibility given his
considerable net worth the programmers
working in the head offices of Martin's
social media company knew he had
somewhat expensive tastes that was what
made it all the more baffling that he
bought what looked to be a very poor
quality Western knockoff of a
traditional Japanese Samurai weapon the
metal it was forged from seemed to be
unpolished unsharpened and unbalanced
overall it just seemed to be a bit of a
mess even to those in the office
unfamiliar with katanas or their
cultural significance in Japan yet when
he described it Martin seemed enamored
with the sword citing how incredible the
balance was and how the obviously very
blunt weapon could more easily slice
through solid steel than one of those
infomercial knives of course the more
pressing and unsettling question for
most of the employees was why the hell
did their boss think it was okay to
bring a katana into the office when any
of the staff working there built up
enough courage to approach their
eccentric sword toing boss to ask him
Martin would simply state that it was a
measure to encourage more productivity
if he was unhappy with the coding work
his programmers were doing or the
content being posted to his social media
site Martin would start strutting around
the office his head was always tilted
back smugly looking down his nose at his
staff who he'd sometimes affect
sectionally call his underlings or
drones with a look of self-importance
superiority and one hand constantly
resting on the hilt of his Catana his
productivity patrols managed to put
everyone in the office on edge less
because they were threatened by the
blunted sword or Martin's unimposing 5
1/2t stature but more because the staff
all agreed that what he was doing was
just plain weird one morning Ned one of
the staff members working at the office
was casually sitting at his computer
working his way through rewriting a few
lines of code as he's been asked to
suddenly he felt something cold in metal
resting on his shoulder and felt the
presence of someone leaning over him
uncomfortably close on the left
immediately his heart jumped in Surprise
and fear only to instantly Dro back down
to a normal beat when he remembered that
Martin's sword was barely sharper than a
butter knife hey Mr zeilberger Ned
sighed hey there nedre Martin replied
his voice sounded like he was trying to
smile but also didn't know know how long
it was normal to hold it also Ned's name
wasn't short for nedre you know you were
asked to finish up this coding an hour
ago he continued even though Ned had
only been told the code needed rewriting
that long ago if you don't hurry up I
might just have to chop you into bits
with my huge sword Martin forced to
laugh as though he'd never actually
expressed humor before eventually the
employees had grown sick of Martin's
brandishing his Katana around the office
they didn't feel threatened so much as
they were just annoyed it was
distracting them from actually doing
their jobs when a group of them led by
Ned marched into his office to formally
complain in solidarity Martin spun
around to face them in his desk chair
his useless sword in his hand so this is
treason then he smiled to himself as if
he'd been waiting for this moment
drawing the katana in his head Martin
was about to Leap Forward over his desk
in a move ripped straight out of a Star
Wars movie he thought he would easily
spin through the air hurdling towards
his group oflo employees with a blade
ready to skewer the nearest ones for
daring to question his leadership
unfortunately despite his surfing trips
in Hawaii Martin wasn't exactly Nimble
enough to pull it off he barely jumped
high enough off the ground to clear the
desk knocking the whole thing forward
and tumbling over it Landing awkwardly
the tip of the blade barely reached far
enough to lightly graze Ned at the front
of the group instead all of Martin's
employees looked at him pathetically
laying face down on the office carpet
after changing hands who knows exactly
how many times the Tana of apparent
invincibility would soon find itself in
the hands of another Soul just as worthy
of wielding it and making themselves
look really dumb in the process for as
long as he could remember Zach had been
obsessed with superheroes he had spent
his youth reading comic books idolizing
characters like Batman who fought
criminals on the Mean Streets to deliver
Swift and brutal Justice even as he got
older Zach never outgrew that childhood
dream he had held on to to become a real
life superhero now obviously he knew
that superhuman Powers were a little out
of his reach but that never stopped
Bruce Wayne Zach could train himself
build up his physical strength and learn
to fight of course he overlooked the
part where Bruce Wayne also had billions
of dollars inherited from his parents at
his disposal not to mention a cave with
lots of fancy high-tech gadgets an
English butler and had trained under
some of the most skilled hand-to-hand
combatants in the entire world Batman
never learned karate during night
classes h at the local Community College
still there was nothing that could deter
Zach from his heroic aspirations he
spent every free moment he had in the
gym lifting weights and building his
biceps to the size of burger buns after
failing his exam twice he achieved the
coveted blue belt in his martial arts
class and he even ordered the parts he
would need to construct his super suit
sure Zach told himself it might have
just looked like a ski mask and some
hockey pads but he needed freedom of
movement as well as protection
there was only one piece left to
complete this stage of his origin story
a kick-ass superhero code name that was
when fate seemed to step in taking its
rarest of forms an eBay listing for a
used sword from the moment he saw it
Zach knew he needed to own it not all
superheroes used weapons but he figured
it would be a good deterrent he'd only
ever draw his blade to wound and only
when there was no other option as he
placed his bed captain Katana was born
it was his first nightly Patrol Zach had
dawned his protective suit and concealed
his secret identity behind the mask the
katana was sheathed and strapped to his
back for now but he was sure enough it
would soon see its share of righteous
Vengeance before the night was over well
more accurately it would cause more than
its share of mishaps by the end of the
night but Zach sorry Captain Katana
didn't care he felt Unstoppable in fact
ever since the sword had arrived in the
mail he had been feeling like he could
take on the world the wouldbe hero
thought it was just the anticipation of
finally being what he'd always wanted to
be exactly what his training had been
preparing for how was he to know that
the sword itself was the reason for his
dangerous amount of overconfidence you
see while it might not be imbued with
ancient magic the power of a God or the
ability to suck the souls of its victims
there is one thing remarkable about SCP
okay well two things the first being
just how bad it is as a sword it isn't
forged from any highquality steel or
made by an elusive Japanese swordsmith
whereas a katana made with the proper
amount of skill craftsmanship and Care
is perfectly weighted and balanced
evenly for the right amount of speed and
swiftness in combat this one is well
none of the above and as if it wasn't
bad enough that it lacked all the other
qualities of a true Katana SCP 572 blade
is totally blunt seriously you couldn't
even slice bread with this thing and yet
in his heart Zach felt like it was the
perfect weapon the most powerful tool in
his vigilante war on crime speaking of
crimes he thought he'd found his first
prey for his nightly hunt the sound of a
car alarm was blaring through the city
streets coming from somewhere nearby our
willfully underere equipped and
underprepared hero raced a few blocks
over to find the source from a distance
all you could see was a man fumbling
with the door of a locked car clearly
unable to open it and trying to force
his way in what this so-called hero
didn't think to do was assess the
situation for any further context too
quick to trust in his
instincts right there he declared unable
to hear how muffled his voice sounded
when filtered through the material of
the ski mask the man froze and turned to
look at the figure approaching him only
to raise an eyebrow in confusion ah
hello he called back can I can I help
you silence villain the Mast onlooker
shouted just audibly over the noisy Car
Alarm you've got two choices here either
you walk away leave that person's
property alone and I'll let you off with
a warning or we do this the hard way and
you'll face Zach paused for dramatic
effect like he practiced in the mirror
the wrath of Captain Katana of who the
other man replied look man I'm not sure
what your deal is if this is some kind
of Cosplay thing or you're just nut
but this is my car okay the door gets
stuck I just need to jimy it a little
sometimes but it sets the alarm off wire
Captain Katana yelled reaching over his
shoulder his gloved hand gripped the
hilt of his weapon and pulled it free of
its sheath from across the parking lot
the driver couldn't tell how utterly
useless the sword was at his current
distance all he saw was a masked
potentially unhinged stranger
dramatically pacing towards him with
what was very clearly a weapon what the
hell he exclaimed urgently trying trying
to get his car door open the handle gave
way and the door sprung open allowing
the man to hurriedly climb into the
driver's seat and shut the door behind
him starting the engine the lights came
on and illuminated The Stranger in front
of him who stood looking absolutely
ridiculous in his outfit consisting of
what looked like various pieces of
sportsware katana in hand the superhero
was still striding slowly towards the
car as the engine spluttered into life
Zach stopped smiling under the material
of his hockey mask as he gripped both
hands around on the hilt and took a wide
stance flooring the accelerator the
driver was eager to get away from the
obvious lunatic even if he was wielding
a sword that was mostly unusable it
didn't seem like that would stop Captain
Katana from trying to use it no matter
how unsuccessfully the car came
barreling towards Zach and he readied
himself lifting the blade high above his
head he knew that he would be able to
bring it downwards in a Victorious swipe
at precisely the right moment the second
the worn out D metal connected with that
of the car it would slice the stolen
vehicle into two perfect pieces split
right down the middle leaving the thief
confounded and ready to be handed over
to police you can already guess that's
not what happened can you with barely a
screech of tires against the concrete
and without even enough distance to
build up that much speed the car headed
straight for Captain Katana he made a
flailing uncoordinated swing far too
early causing the sword to bounce right
off the hood of the car the force of the
impact wasn't huge but it was enough to
cause the katana to slip from the
wannabe Hero's hands helped by the fact
his gloves didn't have that much grip on
them the katana of apparent
invincibility was sent sailing through
the air and came clattering to the
ground rolling under another car in the
parking lot although Zach was a little
preoccupied to see where it landed no
sooner had he lost his grip on his
Almighty weapon of Justice around 32,000
lb of metal collided with Captain Katana
felt on his first ever night as a
superhero by his very first villain
still Zach at least learned what his
Kryptonite was his greatest weakness
just like so many classic superheroes
had his just happened to be being hit by
a midsize sedan tumbling back onto the
ground the back of Captain katana's head
thumped heavily against the cold hard
concrete leaving him with a concussion
and an overwhelming sense of
embarrassment as the driver parked his
car and called an ambulance at least he
now knew he never wanted to pick up that
sword again you see that that's the
second remarkable thing about SCP
572 anyone who picks it up instantly
perceives it as a mighty weapon the kind
you would find in an ancient legend
despite the sword being crudely made
blunt and generally unfit for any use
the wielder will maintain the belief
that it not only has perfect balance and
cutting power but that the sword has
also imbued them with unparalleled
strength and invincibility to damage
it's all a delusion of course and
whoever holds that sword will gladly
prove it to you they'll try to perform
incredibly risky stunts with it only to
end up severely injuring themselves in
the process don't worry though if you
ever come across SCP 572 it's nothing a
quick thump in the back of the head
won't fix when you work for the SCP
Foundation One certainty is that nothing
no turn of events no scenario is ever
really unexpected no matter how unlikely
something may appear chances are it
usually happens and if it doesn't happen
here then in an infinite Multiverse of
Alternatives everything that can
possibly happen is statistically likely
to we've covered a few of these
alternate eventualities before a number
of which revolve around the differing
events in the long life of one
particular anomaly SCP 076-2 better
known as AEL in our home Universe much
like he is and many others AEL is
considered to be a near-perfect warrior
his body covered in tattoos of occultt
symbols and demonic faces is capable of
withstanding vast amounts of physical
damage able can easily take hits from
the most powerful Conventional Weapons
mankind has to offer and survive with
little more than a scratch what's more
he can draw an endless supply of black
bladed weapons from a tiny pocket
Dimension and on top of all of that even
in the event that he's bested in combat
Abel's body will rapidly disintegrate
only to reform with in a large Stone
Cube known as SCP
0761 like most of us Abel has a number
of almost identical counterparts that
exist across the various worlds of the
Multiverse one of them once had the
opportunity to reconcile with his
brother Cain the man seemingly
responsible for Abel's endless life of
Bloodshed and once the two brothers had
made peace they could rest In Another
Universe AEL worked directly with the
SCP Foundation as part of a mobile task
force until they turned on him this
unfurled the chain of events so
cataclysmic that the entire world
suffered the consequences this alternate
Abel went on a war path against the
foundation ultimately using SCP 914 the
Clockworks to refine his destructive
anomalous abilities this allowed him to
unleash chaos slaughtering all of
humanity in an omnisite that wiped the
world clean of all other life leaving
Abel alone in a dead world and then
there was this vers version of The
Immortal Warrior far from the Clockwork
enhanced conqueror that his alternate
universe counterpart was this AEL had
long since been removed as a member of
MTF Omega 7 and was gradually
reconstituting his body within SCP
0761 his most recent defeat had enraged
the warrior and he had vowed to once
again be free although unbeknownst to
him what set this particular version of
Abel apart from his other variants was
the fact that he would soon encounter a
certain other anomaly something that
when wielded by SCP 076-2 had the
potential to completely Rob him of all
his centuries worth of fighting ability
and replace it with an embarrassment
that would last for centuries more but
first a quick history lesson much like
it had been in our universe this
particular anomalous object had been
recovered by the foundation after made
its way into the hands of an unwitting
police officer the item in question was
SCP 572 a particularly unique Katana
unique in that it was utterly useless
for fighting with and caused more harm
to the person wielding it than whoever
they were trying to use it against in
this universe the sword had already
changed hands a number of times when
police were called to the home of one
Clarence Clancy clerson he drew SCP 572
in defense and screamed at the officers
that he would quote take their heads and
with it their power the cops who had
been sent over to arrest claim clany for
violent and disorderly Behavior were
less than threatened to see their
suspect who was somewhat out of shape
coming at them with a weapon no sharper
than a butter knife after pacifying
Clancy with tasers and bean bag rounds
from a 12 gauge shotgun the police
retrieved SC SCP 572 and then it was
acquired by a foundation operative this
all played out almost the exact same way
in our universe however in this version
of events there was one key difference
as previously mentioned SC p572 was an
unremarkable sword but it had something
of a storied past passing from one
unfortunate user to the next and just as
it was recovered from Clancy's house and
ended up in Foundation hands one of
those former owners had just been about
to reclaim the fabled weapon for himself
meanwhile back in this containment
chamber deep under the ocean still
trapped in the stone Cube he reanimated
within Abel was lost in a dream to any
other person falling asleep to see
subconscious visions of so much Carnage
would be horrifying they would call it a
nightmare but to Abel this might have
been one of the sweetest dreams that he
had ever experienced all around him was
a world on fire having returned to life
once again able at last vested his
captors at the SCP Foundation in his
dream he traveled the world visiting
every Foundation facility one by one and
reducing them to Rubble without leaving
a single Survivor then once the work was
done he turned his barbarism towards the
wider world and began slaughtering
Humanity in droves perhaps some distant
Cosmic Echo had reached out across the
Multiverse a fragment of the life of a
more refined version of himself had
slipped into Abel's subconsciousness
making him dream that he too was the
omnicidal Conqueror that his other self
was seeing such Devastation in his own
wake made this version of Abel eager to
wake up to revive once more and set
about making this delightful dream of
Destruction a deadly reality it was
while Abel was dreaming picturing
himself cutting down all who dared
oppose him that something strange seemed
to happen he had a visitor not a visitor
to his containment chamber mind you
there was no one beyond the confines of
SCP 0761 except the security team that
normally kept the stone Cube under armed
surveillance no this visitor appeared
somewhere else inside Abel's mind
approaching him as he slept within the
Warrior's slumbering fantasy he was
climbing up a mountain of skulls after
having slaughtered Millions if not
billions already but as he reached the
top of the pile of bones and looked out
over the horizon able could see that the
world Beyond was still living there were
just as many people alive perhaps even
more that he'd already killed his work
was not yet done in fact it seemed that
despite all the lives The Immortal
Madmen had already claimed seemed he had
barely even begun oh AEL a voice tutted
did you really think you could do it
alone even though this was a dream Abel
could feel the presence of another he
pulled one of his obsidian edged weapons
from thin air and swiped in the
direction The Voice had come from
hitting nothing the blade in his hand
seemed to change its dark metal
transforming from solid to liquid coming
apart in his hands ael's sword melted
like candle wax under a hot flame
reduced to nothing in seconds you can't
do it the voice whispered you aren't
strong enough but I can help with that
pulling out another weapon a two-handed
axe this time Abel looked around him
trying to locate the source of the
taunting noise only a coward relies on
cheap tricks and Illusions he growled
angrily show yourself come forward and
be slain are you a worthy opponent are
you worth your time are you the voice
gested we shall see Abel yelled behind
him a cloak figure silently appeared
they looked to be adorned in a robe that
whipped in the biting cold wind yet
their garments weren't made of any
fabric instead they wore a robe made out
of pure Shadow their clothes and body
comprised of the same thing though they
lacked any tangible solid matter it
didn't stop Abel from spinning around
swinging his heavy axe in the figure's
direction before the blade of the weapon
was even halfway through the air it had
already started to become come liquid
just like the swords had earlier by the
time it came down to strike at the
shadowy visitor what had once been an
axe was just a flick of melted black
metal passing through the intangible
Spectre as Abel found himself once again
unarmed speak Katon he demanded never
one to back away from a fight even when
his weapons were seemingly failing him
tell me who you are I would like to know
my adversary's name before I end your
worthless life I am not here to fight
you the figure replied calmly I'm here
to offer you the key to your Victory AEL
what key the warrior sneered what could
you possibly give me exactly what you
need to finish it the shadow replied
drawing something from a sheath on its
belt and holding it aoft a weapon that
will allow you to become the Conqueror
you long to be Abel looked at the object
in the figure's outstretched hand a
katana or at least the shadowy vestage
of one a sword he sneered what use do I
have for a sword I can conjure all the
blades I needed will to demonstrate
abble pulled one of his own black blades
but yet again it began to melt away your
weapons have served you well but they
are disposable the shadow explained a
true warrior deserves a sword worthy of
his fighting prowess I have killed
scores of men throughout the ages The
Immortal Warrior retorted and I never
needed any special sword to do that and
that is why no matter how many you
killed you will always be beaten in his
dream Abel paused a moment looking at
the katana and considering then he
reached his hand out to grip the shadowy
hilt in that same Split Second SCP 076-2
awoke once again from his Slumber and
broke free of the stone Cube encasing
him as he killed his way through the
foundation Personnel in the facility
housing SCP
0761 Abel had only one thought in mind
he needed that sword you see what the
immortal Maniac was unfortunately
totally unaware of was the interesting
effect SCP 572 could have on people as
well as being a totally useless sword
anyone who picked it up will instantly
believe the katana of apparent
invincibility to be an all powerful
weapon of ancient legend despite the
sword being crudely made blunt and
generally unfit for any use the wielder
will maintain the belief that it not
only has perfect balance and cutting
power but that the sword has also imbued
them with unparalleled strength and
invincibility to damage and now either
through the sword itself extending this
Cognito hazardous influence into Abel's
dream or by the interference of some
unknown trickery one of the most
dangerous and anomalous killers in the
world was making a beline straight for
SCP 572 and he wasn't the only one
either at a previous point in time a man
by the name of Zach had purchased CP 572
on eBay but it was far more than just an
oddity to him he wasn't looking to start
a sword collection as a child he had
been obsessed with comic book
superheroes and when Zach bought that
Katana he intended to use the blade to
dispense vigilante justice against those
who prayed on the innocent and even
before he held it in his hands Zach 2
felt the anomalous pull of the katana
knowing in his heart it was the perfect
weapon to transform him into a hero of
course he had quickly been disproven
when on his first night of crime
fighting Zach had been hit by a midsize
sedan in a multi-story parking lot and
suffered a concussion sent to the
hospital and then charged with attempted
assault Zach had long since lost any and
all interest in ever Dawning his costume
comprised of hockey pads and a ski mask
or picking up the sword ever again but
as time had gone on that old familiar
pole had started to gnaw at Zach urging
him to get back in the superhero game
forgetting how poorly that had worked
out for him last time one problem still
stood in his way though he needed his
trusty sword back of course in the time
since he'd hung up his hero outfit
glancy had gotten his hands on SCP 572
and then right before Zach could steal
it back the foundation had taken it it
had taken him months of preparation he'd
sneakily made dealings with a janitor
that worked at one of the foundation's
sites Zach had bribed the man a lot of
money in exchange for his key card and
uni form even having to take out a
second mortgage on his apartment to meet
the frankly extortionate amount the
janitor asked for but it would be worth
the cost Zach told himself if it
reunited him with his trusty Katana then
it would be worth it only then would he
once again be a full hero shuffling
through the facility Zach dragged a mop
over the floor leaving a sign to warn
the slippery Hazard he whistled to
himself trying to act as casually as
possible not realizing that he was
slightly overselling it once he was
certain the coast was clear he made his
move SCP 572 was locked in a secure
deposit box within sight 19's high value
item storage facility right where he had
been cleaning he began searching through
the various anomalous Oddities kept
there until he saw it the Box containing
his coveted sword all his effort in
infiltrating the foundation had finally
paid off it was all leading to this his
comeback in crime fighting it was at
this precise moment moment that Abel
came bursting through a nearby door
completely befuddled Zach quickly found
himself thrown to one side by the much
stronger man out of my way weakling Abel
roared before turning to face the
deposit box holding SCP 572 gripping the
Box Abel used his superhuman strength to
tear it open as though the container was
made from cardboard there it was stored
safely within was the weapon he had been
seeking the same all powerful sword from
his vision at last he deed glared
reaching for the hilt this sword belongs
to me the second that Abel hoisted it
into the air he felt a human weight
dashed towards him only to shrug it off
as it made impact Zach tumbled to the
floor winded as AEL barely flinched at
the attempted tackle you fool he roared
you dare come at me you'll be the first
to fall to my new Blade the first of
this pathetic world of unworthy
opponents to die in my Conquest Zach
frighteningly raised his arms in an
attempt to Shield himself when Abel
raised the sword menacingly above his
head the Mortal man knew what the sword
was capable of or so he thought as Abel
brought the blade swiping downwards its
true ineffectiveness as a melee weapon
was on fold display SCP 572 dull poorly
balanced blade barely grazed Zach's arms
as he protected his face in fact beyond
the initial SWAT it barely hurt I I
don't understand Abel stammered looking
at the katana in confusion
this is meant to be a warrior blade a
weapon of Champions and conquerors yeah
that's what I was thinking Zach replied
also suffering fromp 572 Cognito
hazardous effect he'd fully expected to
die a second ago slain by the very
weapon he had been hoping to reclaim
still maybe it's just because it's your
first go I could show you how to silence
I will not fall for that Abel
interrupted let me see here maybe the
angle was off or how about I use both
hands here let me just once again able
hoisted the weapon this time with both
hands tightly gripping the blade
intending to bring it slashing down in a
big swing like a Woodsman cleaving a log
and two unfortunately as he raised the
sword the blade caught in exposed light
fixture above Sparks burst from the
ceiling as an electrical current shot
through the metal and gave Abel a nasty
shock oh God what is the meaning of this
he shouted in frustration I've been
alive for centuries killed thousands
upon thousands of men since the dawn of
civilization why can't I use this
well performance issues for a guy your
age hardly an uncommon problem Zach
joked both turned at the sound of a door
kicked open the clump of heavy boots on
the ground as a foundation security team
burst in SCP 076-2 drop your weapons in
the commander stopped mid shout wait
that's not one of his regular swords is
it sir um that's uh one of the officers
paused inside I think that's SCP
572 attack me abble yelled at the
foundation officers pointing the dull
tip of the katana at them if you dare
for now I will the greatest blade known
to the universe you will all fall in a
single stroke of my new weapon and once
you have fallen so shall the world CP
076-2 able look just put the thing down
the commander urged uh trust me you'll
you'll thank yourself H you pathetic
fools are so afraid of the chaos I will
unleash the warrior declared
such unworthy opponents okay I've seen
enough the security Commander sighed
deadly force authorized light them up
boys on the Commander's signal a hail of
gunfire erupted bullets raining down on
AEL he slashed SCP 572 through the air
certain that what he thought was a
mighty sword could easily cut through
the oncoming bullets of course that may
have been true if SCP 572 is only real
power was not having any power at all
each shot struck a aable Center Mass
barely damaging him given his body's
natural resilience to harm particularly
from such Small Arms fire although he
didn't find it any less annoying that he
couldn't seem to properly wield his new
Katana oh are you kidding me he huffed
to himself what is with me today can't
get the hang of this thing come on a but
Ste a sword the weapon that will allow
me to conquer this whole world but if I
can just get the swing right calmly
knowing that the weapon itself posed no
threat even in the hands of an immortal
mass murderer the security team moved in
to apprehend AEL before they could take
the katana from his hands he dashed
towards them swiping the sword back and
forth hoping to at least hit someone to
get the ball rolling on his omnicidal
Rampage instead thanks to the influence
of SCP 572 he miscalculated took a wrong
step and slipped over on a patch of
freshly moed tile Landing in a heap next
to a wet floor sign the security Team
all wined feeling the secondhand
embarrassment practically ly radiating
off of AEL as the ancient anomalous
Warrior lay on the floor after a
spectacular fall then one by one they
all burst out into uncontrollable fits
of laughter but while they were
distracted they were completely
oblivious to Zach who emerged from his
hiding place and picked SCP 572 up off
the floor he breathed to S relief
reunited with his priced weapon having
forgotten the severe injury it caused
him last time you Abel wheezed still
lying in a puddle of mop water who are
you Zach gave a slight smile unzipping
the janitor's overalls he had on to
reveal a set of hockey pads underneath
he slipped a ski mask over his face
before turning back to Abel and replying
in his most epic voice I'm captain
Katana unfortunately his return to crime
fighting would be as shortlived as
Abel's own turn with SCP 572 as Captain
Katana found himself hit by a bus on his
way home after trying to use the katana
of apparent invincibility to to cut set
bus in half down the middle and failing
in a rather painful fashion if you've
ever read the book of Genesis which is
the part of the Old Testament that
details God creating the world and
Humanity during a particularly busy week
then you might just be already familiar
with SCP 001 or at least one of the
anomalies that's been proposed for the
title of SCP
001 because of course SCP 001 doesn't
refer to a single creature object or
entity but rather a collection of
various anomalies contained by the SCP
Foundation anomalies sharing the name SC
SCP 001 include the infamous Scarlet
King a powerful eldrich being intent on
ending all of creation that is thought
by Foundation researchers to be one of
the most dangerous beings in this and
any other universe but the Scarlet King
isn't the only incredibly powerful being
categorized as SCP 001 in fact there are
plenty of other an IES with similar
levels of destructive power and one such
being is a creature codenamed the gate
Guardian standing at well over 1,000 ft
tall the gate Guardian is impossible to
be fully contained by any means that the
foundation possesses the anomaly itself
despite its colossal size is humanoid in
its shape sporting wings that protrude
from its back while it usually has four
of these SCP 001 has historically been
seen to have any number of wings between
two and 108 sprouting from various
places over its body including its
shoulders ankles wrists and even its
temples this gigantic Guardian also
carries its own weapon referred to as
SCP
0012 this weapon resembles an enormous
knife or sword capable of emitting
plumes of flame according to tests
conducted by the foundation the
temperature of the Flames produced by
SCP 001 rival that of her very own son
for reference the Sun has a core
temperature of over 27 million de F and
5,778 Kelvin at its surface or almost
10,000 de F you would expect a flaming
sword that burns hotter than the sun to
cause a considerable amount of damage
even if it wasn't in use but the Flames
emitted by the weapon leave no lasting
damage on the surrounding environment it
is capable though of annihilating
anything that Strays too close to SCP
001 burning them so intensely that their
atoms literally separate breaking
potential attackers apart on a molecular
level much as its code name suggests the
gate Guardian stands solemnly at the
threshold of some form of dimensional
Gateway which is equally tall as
scp1 itself behind the guardian is a
lush Grove abundant with fruit trees of
astronomical size as well as other
beings that share a similar appearance
to SCP
001 this Grove is thought to be be the
Garden of Eden the paradise that God
created and that was inhabited by Adam
and Eve the first two humans in
existence according to the Book of
Genesis as the tale goes the pair were
created by God himself and permitted to
live in the Garden of Eden as long as
they followed a single rule Adam and Eve
were instructed not to eat any of the
fruit That Grew From certain trees that
God had specified within view just
behind the gate Guardian are two immense
trees one bearing Apple and the other
bearing different fruit of an unknown
type the one that looks like an apple
tree is believed even by some in the
foundation to be the biblical tree of
knowledge that Eve was convinced to pick
a fateful Apple from after an encounter
with a snake the other the one with
unidentifiable fruit is thought to be
the tree of life however this is all
speculation since it is currently
impossible to venture through this
Gateway and verify if the realm Beyond
is truly the Bible's own garden of Eden
this is largely because anything that
breaches a kilometer wide radius of SCP
001 is instantly vaporized the gate
Guardian attacks with imperceptible
speed using its flaming sword to Smite
any person that gets too close the
guardian actually moves so fast that it
can hardly be seen with the naked eye it
appears to always remain in its solemn
dutiful stance with its weapon drawn and
head bowed only shifting for a fraction
of a nond to attack ranged attacks
against the Guardian are just as
ineffective with all projectiles fired
at SCP 001 reduced to atoms before they
can do any harm even if said projectile
happens to be a nuclear weapon the gate
Guardian will be able to sub atomically
vaporize both the projectile itself as
well as the person who sent it
regardless of how far away they are all
while not appearing to lift a finger
during an experiment involving SCP 001
on December 26th 2004 an SCP Foundation
new nuclear submarine called Nautilus
launched a series of multi- Warhead
intercontinental ballistic missiles at
the gate Guardian the retaliation from
the guardian resulted not only in the
deaths of approximately 35,000 innocent
civilians but the blast is also believed
by some to have inadvertently caused the
2004 Boxing Day tsunami the severity of
this incident came dangerously close to
revealing the foundation's existence to
the world resulting in them rapidly
deploying any means necessary to erase
any trace of the 35,000 victim's
families friends and other related
individuals in order to avoid
questioning the SCP Foundation
administered amnestics on an almost
worldwide scale and the 05 Council
banned any further tests on SCP 001 that
involved nuclear weapons in what was
hoped by the foundation to be a test
with lower Stakes they sent an
Expendable d-class Personnel towards SCP
001 the d-class approached the area
where the gate Guardian is located and
as soon as they saw it they could hear a
very clear command in their mind leave
the d-class Personnel reacted exactly
the same way you or I would they
promptly turned and started to walk away
they didn't need a thft tall entity with
a flaming sword to tell them twice the
researchers running the experiment were
not swayed by the request and ordered
the declass to continue moving towards
SCP 001 when the d-class continued to
ignore their commands they were
terminated as his standard policy when
dealing with an insubordinate member of
d-class SCP 001 appeared not to like
this for some reason though and the
researcher site as well as the
researchers themselves were immediately
obliterated by an unknown Force though
it's a pretty safe guess that a certain
flaming weapon was responsible this
candidate for scp1 may be one of if not
the most powerful being that the SCP
Foundation has ever encountered and
according to its entry in the SCP 001
file the guardian is even responsible
for the creation of the foundation
itself if the file is to be believed the
administrator of the SCP Foundation One
Day heard a word echoing through his
head
prepare this one-word instruction led
him to starting the SCP Foundation
containing countless dangerous anomalies
and entities in preparation for an
uncertain future in all that time since
the very beginning of the foundation the
gate Guardian has remained standing at
its post while it is not aggressive nor
openly hostile towards Humanity the gate
Guardian doesn't seem to care much for
us either at least as individuals it
rarely interacts with human beings when
left unprovoked and venturing too close
to the guardian however is not an
automatic death sentence the guardian
first communicates with any living being
approaching it via telepathic message
instructing them to either leave or
forget if whomever has stepped too close
to SCP 001 complies with the
instructions they'll be able to freely
leave the area while simultaneously
forgetting every detail of the gate
guardian's existence ignore These
Warnings though and SCP 001 has no
qualms about completely eliminating you
from reality given its enormous
destructive potential it is no wonder
that the foundation has tried to use the
gate Guardian to eliminate other
dangerous scps each with varying results
the foundation at one time even
attempted to use the gate Guardian to
destroy the infamously indestructible
SCP 682 better known by the appropriate
name of the hardto destroy reptile due
to the malicious contempt SCP 682 holds
for human beings and all other forms of
life it is perhaps one of the most
dangerous anomalies the SCP Foundation
has in containment SCP 682 is also one
of the few creatures the foundation
actively wants wants to terminate a task
made that much harder given that 682 can
regenerate its entire form from as
little as a single cell the gate
Guardian had already shown time and time
again that it was capable of massive
destruction and researchers working for
the foundation hoped to harness that
power to rid the world of SCP 682 for
good 682 was placed on an unmanned
vehicle and carried to within 1 km of
the gate Guardian the guardian attacked
the vehicle seriously wounding but not
killing 682 it seemed even the mighty
SCP 001 couldn't kill the hardto destroy
reptile while the researchers were
disappointed with this result it is
worth noting that 682 made a very
interesting comment to the guardian 682
mentioned that the gate Guardian is not
uel but a pretender uel is the arch
angel that some religious texts describe
as the guardian standing at the Gate of
Eden with a fiery sword so does this
mean that 682 knows that the gate
Guardian is not actually an angel or
that the location it is guarding isn't
the Garden of Eden at all any truth or
meaning behind these comments has as of
yet been undetermined by the SCP
Foundation a later experiment involved
both SCP 001 and SCP 073 the anomaly
otherwise known as Cain Cain is a male
humanoid of possible Arabic descent
whose arms legs spine and shoulders are
replaced in an almost cyborg like
fashion with burum bronze much like the
gate Guardian SCP 073 may also be the
same as the one mentioned in the Bible's
Book of Genesis who according to the
biblical story murdered his own brother
Abel out of spite as punishment for his
actions Cain was cursed to eternally
suffer for his wrongdoing in the case of
SCP 073 any damage inflicted on him is
deflected back to the attacker but Cain
is made to feel the pain of the attack
any plants or plant-based matter Withers
and rots in his presence and and he is
cursed with a perfect memory keeping him
forever haunted by his murder of AEL
when C was brought before the gate
Guardian an unknown incident occurred
the foundation's records are heavily
expunged but we do know that somehow
kan's usual ability to deflect incoming
damage back at his attacker had no
effect on SCP
001 the encounter left SCP 073
unconscious and even permanently blinded
nearby research Personnel it was as a
direct result of this incident that the
05 Council demanded that no further
experiments of any kind were to be
conducted on SCP 001 with the
administrator even filing an executive
order that no scps be exposed to the
guardian and that SCP 001 was to never
be used for the attempted termination of
other
scps of course perhaps it wasn't just
the mistakes of the past that made the
council decide that SCP 001 was best
left alone at some point an erratic
transmission was received from site Zero
by Foundation Personnel detailing an XK
Class end of the world scenario in the
transmission the sender believed to be
another member of the SCP Foundation
described an event during which the gate
Guardian finally left its post stepping
away from the entrance to the Garden of
Eden SCP 001 has left its location the
sender wrote the gate is open they are
riding forth oh God it's so beautiful
the transmission then goes on to repeat
various phrases including the Lord shall
reign forever and here o Israel the Lord
Our God the Lord is one what can be
inferred from the rambling transmission
is that the event being described is the
end of the world some believe that once
God deems at time his Angelic armies
will lay Wass to the Earth in order to
remake it as a paradise when this occurs
as CP 001 the gate Guardian will open
the gate he stands in front of allowing
the other beings like it to emerge merem
merge into our world ready to cleanse it
perhaps most interesting is the source
of the message the transmission was
received from within the foundation from
site zero however when questioned by
Personnel 05-14 told them that no such
message had been sent or even existed
while some disregarded the transmission
telling of the end of the world as a
hoax it was then that a time stamp was
discovered this warning had not been
sent from site zero at least not yet and
was has dated several years in the
future despite this ominous warning of
things to come the gate Guardian remains
inactive standing at the threshold to
Eden waiting any changes today the
younger security officer Zach asked as
he stepped into the Watch Tower as if
replied his Superior a jaded cynical old
man who insisted on being referred to as
Mr Jefferson the darn thing hasn't moved
spoken or done so much as stretch one of
those wings of his another day at the
office as then zacho through the window
the pair of them looked through at the
Towering figure a few kilomet away SCP
001 the gate Guardian stood motionless
its fiery sword in its hand ever
protecting its post at the precipice
between our world and Paradise it had
long been stationed at the entrance of a
dimensional Gateway that led to what was
believed to be the Garden of Eden
described in the biblical Old Testament
much like the security officers in the
foundations Bas tasked with watching The
Guardian this was pretty much the extent
of the day's activities hey did you see
that news about the uh transfer posting
Zack asked trying to saave off boredom
with as much conversation he could
squeeze out of his fellow officer yeah I
saw Mr Jefferson scoffed rolling his
eyes what possesses someone like Robert
Monto to come down here must have wanted
a quieter post Zach Reon looking out at
the Stillness of the gate Guardian won't
find one any quieter than here Jefferson
mused him showing up will be the most
exciting thing that's happened here in a
long while unbeknownst to both Zach and
Mr Jefferson Dr Robert Monto would be
only joining the team at the gate
Guardian observation site for a short
while not one of them nor anybody else
within the foundation could ever guess
monto's true intentions behind venturing
there in the first place he wanted an
audience with a gate Guardian itself
approaching the Colossal thft tall being
Dr Mon talk crossed the threshold of the
minimum safe distance from the guardian
given the sheer heat of its weapon
hotter than Earth's sun anything within
a kilometer of SCP 001 was at risk of
being obliterated vaporized into atoms
if they didn't turn back which through a
voice that immediately rang out in
monto's ears the gate Guardian commanded
him to
do its psychic message boomed wait wait
Dr Monto urged holding up his hand hands
in what would have been a futile defense
against the Guardian Sword I know what
you do when people don't listen to your
commands but please just give me a
minute there was silence SCP 001 didn't
reply there was nobody else close enough
to hear Monto speak to it so he
continued you are impossibly old we know
that much about you and because of that
you must have seen things that we can't
even begin to imagine much less fully
comprehend but I've come a very long way
to request that you impart some
information to me if you can he paused
again as if waiting for a reply that
never came the gate Guardian merely
stood in the same defensive unwavering
stance tell me please how much do you
know about the Scarlet King by this
point in time although the foundation
was yet to realize Dr Robert Monto was
slowly going insane his investigations
into an anomalous entity known as The
Scarlet King were gradually corrupt in
him as he tried relentlessly to quantify
exactly what this entity was and how
great of a threat it posed little did
monok realize that in trying so hard to
Define and comprehend the being he was
inadvertently fueling its power the
Scarlet King was an interdimensional War
mongerer an embodiment of hatred and
chaos and Dr Robert Monto was slowly
falling under the king's influence upon
hearing the tiny human figure utter his
question the amens gate Guardian rebed
with another single word psychic command
one it had never been recorded giving
before
witness as if his increasing instability
and the creeping influence of the
Scarlet King hadn't made Monto feel bad
enough he instantly felt sick there was
a searing pain behind his eyes like he
was staring directly at the sun
accompanied by a nausea that made his
head spin it took a moment of enduring
the horrific s sensation before he
realized what was happening the guardian
was trying to show him something rather
than give any information on the Scarlet
King verbally SCP 001 was imparting a
psychic Vision onto mon a memory of
events long past the answers he sought a
warning or perhaps all three the vision
showed monok a time so long ago that it
couldn't ever be forgotten for there was
barely anyone alive to remember it in
the first place it was e on in the past
long before the comparatively recent
dawn of humanity a time only spoken of
in the dust and blood tablet an artifact
of the dite civilization some of the
earliest worshippers of the Scarlet King
himself and there marching up to the
entrance of Eden was the Crimson clad
eldrich Abomination and a horde of
Horrors with him according to the story
recorded in the dust and blood tablet
this would have been much earlier in the
life of the Scarlet King perhaps even
even before he assumed his now Infamous
title back then he would most likely
have been known as his original name of
KRA one of multiple siblings born when
the tree of life was planted and thus
created all life in the Multiverse but
being the only one of his siblings
cursed with awareness knowing the pain
his existence brought him krock would
eventually set out on his lifelong
mission to destroy all of existence
across every Dimension and he started by
killing his siblings consuming them to
claim their power for himself around
this time in prehistory the being that
would one day become known as Scarlet
King didn't quite possess the power that
he would several Millennia later
although that's not to say he was an
unformidable force of Destruction fueled
by his singular hatred for existence his
vow to destroy extended to the tree of
life that had caused him to be along
with the tre's Creator and all of their
Creation in other words everything in
the Multiverse all of creation if you
will so what was the Scarlet King doing
there so long ago at the dimensional
doorway protected by the gate Guardian
well beyond the boundary between it and
the rest of the infinite Multiverse lay
the supposed Garden of Eden while it is
unknown if it is in fact the same Eden
referred to in the Book of Genesis is Up
For Debate especially among the
foundation but at a glance even through
the gate it certainly does look like a
paradise the space is filled with Lush
vegetation of astronomical size
populated by a number of beings that
seem to resemble the gate Guardian
itself and there protected by its
watchful caretaker are two trees one is
thought to be the tree of knowledge that
Eve was tricked into eating an apple
from during the Book of Genesis the
other however Bears an unknown type of
fruit and is widely believed to be the
tree of life now back in the Modern Age
there's never been a conclusive link
between the tree of life mentioned by
the davit in their barbaric
civilizations Legends regarding the
creation of the Scarlet King but the
fact that so long ago he and his most
feared generals were bearing down on the
gate guardian's position defending a
garden where there was known to be a
tree of that description well it all
seems rather conclusive now alongside
Kakak were six of his Seven Daughters
each one of them a fearsome Abomination
much like their destructive father as
they approached not one needed to
exchange any words with their Angelic
protector of Eden the gate Guardian knew
what these monsters were here for they
would stop at nothing to pass through
his gate and uproot the Tree of Life the
progenitor of all living beings in all
of existence even though it was early in
katar's career as the rampaging
interdimensional warlord he so is he was
as steadfast as ever in his goal to
annihilate every corner of creation
every Dimension every parallel plane of
real reality every single pocket of
existence across Infinity they'd all
come undone if he burned the Tree of
Life hold it out at the roots and
splintered it until nothing remained to
The Once and Future Scarlet King that
the same tree had led to his own
tortured existence it was the source of
his suffering and it had to be destroyed
the only thing standing in his way was a
figure as colossal as karak himself
wielding a flaming sword Le
boomed the psychic voice of the gate
Guardian it was like a doorman standing
before a group of Rowdy teenagers trying
to force their way into a movie theater
except these Rowdy teens were the
Scarlet King his horrifying daughters
and the forces he had already amass
since his creation the hordes stood
ready waiting for the commands of their
King who they thought would gladly lead
the charge as they marched on the Garden
of Eden to begin the destruction of
existence but that's not what happened
usually the Scarlet king would never shy
away from a fight preferring to lead the
charge when it came to a Slaughter
instead he commanded his first daughter
AIC to commence the first attack on the
protector who stood in their path on her
foul father's word AIC took her horde
and charged at the guardian what she and
her forces lacked in numerical Advantage
AIC more than made up for in her
knowledge of War she hungered for it
sought Dominion that was her seal after
all and yet in the the face of this
impending Onslaught the gate Guardian
remains still rooted to the same spot it
had as always and would always be
standing a number of aic's minions burst
into flames the very fabric of their
crude form separated on a molecular
level as they were effortlessly rendered
into nothingness still the gate Guardian
hadn't appeared to move an inch had
exerted no energy despite the damage it
had done to anic and her forces in
defense of Eden as his first daughter
screeched and H called in despair at the
decimation of her horn her children the
Scarlet King decided he needed to better
understand his opponent with a wave of
his clawed Crimson hand the king
commanded his next daughter aor to send
forth her own Army in a tital wave of
nightmarish creatures agor sent her
horrific children into battle she
possessed a far greater quantity to do
battle on her father's behalf perhaps
akar even believed that was the Scarlet
King's plan with a greater number of her
for forces over her sisters maybe she
would be able to overwhelm the guardian
but even as her own children began to be
vaporized the closer that they got to
the gate agor had no idea she was little
more than a pawn being sacrificed so
that KRA could learn more about his
imposing Angelic enemy another of the
Scarlet King's Daughters a being known
as anit was the next called up to
contribute to the unfolding battle
although to call it a battle tells just
how easily the gate Guardians seemed to
be eliminating the oncoming forces
without even moving while an outwardly
frail seeming creature unh's primary
strength over her sisters was a
Proficiency in Magic her inate ability
to warp and reshape reality around her
it was that power that had caused her
father to be wary of her viewing anu's
abilities as a threat to his leadership
and so KRA had her crippled and all her
children leaving them unable to
overthrow him but still loyal to their
King obeying her father's command
perhaps out of the same loyalty or fear
that he would harm her and her children
further if she disobeyed Anu unfurled
her magic she reshaped the world around
them making it so that the passage of
time moves so much slower and that was
what revealed to the Scarlet King his
enemy's greatest strength in combat the
gate Guardian had so far been able to
obliterate both AIC and now aor forces
without seeming to move but it wasn't by
standing still it was moving just was
much faster than the blink of scarlet
King's multiple eyes now that an's magic
had slowed the passage of time the gate
Guardian could be seen doing battle as
agar's atrocities spilled towards the
angel to try and overwhelm it it
effortlessly blocked the oncoming
attacks with its sword everything the
Flaming blade connected with instantly
evaporated bursting into atoms as they
were practically cleaved out of
existence by the gate guardian's Mighty
weapon even with time slowed to a crawl
the powering winged protector of Eden
only appeared to be moving at an average
speed but when time flowed normally
without Anu manipulating reality the
guardian was simply too fast to be
observed resisting the urge to dive head
first into the fight himself the Scarlet
King knew it would likely lead to his
untimely demise he refused to accept
that it could not happen but he still
had yet to amass the strength he would
need as he continued his Ascent so while
time was slow to a crawl and the the
gate Guardian was still engaged in
combat with agoro's forces he turned to
another of his remaining daughters
adista if the Scarlet King and his
forces couldn't get past the guardian
they could still try to get to the Tree
of Life while the protector's focus was
diverted aist Unleashed a wave of
pestilence sickness and disease spewing
from her in a cloud of vapor heading
straight towards the Angelic garden and
Eden's entrance Beyond The Scarlet King
knew this latest attack wouldn't phase
or weaken the gate Guardian he hoped the
foul smog would instead pass through the
Gateway itself into the garden as adad
sent forth her power blood and Ash
soaked the landscape around them all the
plants outside the entrance to Eden
withered and died shriveling and
decomposing as the disgusting fog rolled
towards the gate it washed over the
guardian whose form only seemed to Glow
brighter as he repelled the pestilence
it was as if it didn't even need to
think about it still focused on
finishing off the rest of the the
oncoming Army as its glow intensified so
did the fiery sword that the gate
Guardian swung with ease and finesse
flames burst from the blade the
encroaching fumes Catching Fire along
with the air itself it ignited in a wave
of fire a defensive Inferno that
repelled this latest attack but for a
brief few moments while time stayed slow
before anu's hold on reality inevitably
broke the king had sent forth ATI of all
his spawn she was the most reserved
keeping mostly to herself never speaking
she and her children could change their
faces and forms shift into anything or
anyone and walk undetected through the
Multiverse and now her father was
employing her incredible stealth
abilities to slip Behind Enemy Lines
while the gate Guardian was finishing
off the remaining Onslaught from kak's
other daughters it was as atiff Drew
near creeping unseen closer and closer
to the entrance keeping the Scarlet King
out of Eden that the guardian seemed to
pause it slowly ominously turned its
huge head tilting until it was looking
directly at atli if its expression could
be seen maybe the gate Guardian would
almost be impressed that someone was
able to sneak past it after all it was a
feat that no other being in creation
could ever HED to accomplish but then
again with its steadfast conviction and
dedication to its protective Duty
maybe it would have looked upon atth
with anger with a cleaving swing of its
scorching sword the gate Guardian
unfurled the tidal wave of fire that
engulfed everything around it not just
aif but aik aor and adista all the
king's daughters that had attacked so
far along with every one of their own
children were instantly obliterated they
were all reduced to empty vacant spaces
where they had once been their atoms
separated by the Searing swing of the G
guardian's weapon the devastating Blow
by his adversary did little to deter the
Scarlet King from his mission he was
still set on destroying the tree of life
and no loss was too great in his pursuit
of destroying existence he barely cared
that four of his own daughters had just
been unmade by the guardian anit was
still there Clinging On to time as if it
were a thrashing animal the Scarlet King
could simply make her restore her Fallen
sisters and their forces he had lost
nothing but had help hel back for too
long and slowly drew his own weapon out
of thin air wielding a sword that was as
blood soaked as the Guardians was hot
the Scarlet King locked blades with the
one being standing in their way both the
ancient Angelic Defender and the
attacking eldrich Abomination were
evenly matched every one of their
vicious strikes against the other met
with an equally strong Perry a weapon of
extreme allc consuming heat blocks
swipes from a sharp serrated edge that
that matched the Deep Red that would be
forever synonymous with conrock the
force of their two swords clashing and
striking each other was so great that it
rippled out from their one-on-one fight
the landscape around them was flattened
wiped clean of any remaining plant life
that hadn't already been destroyed by
the forces of the King's Daughters
despite having acquired nowhere near the
power he would thousands of years after
this fight the Scarlet King was still a
formidable force in single combat and
yet the great Guardian seemed incapable
of tiring or weakening still standing
strong against the onslaught even after
wiping multiple armies out with its
flaming sword the guardian was still
able to hold its own against the Scarlet
King who was Furious enraged at being so
close to the tree of life yet unable to
get past his Angelic adversary he needed
to be stronger faster even more ruthless
than the warlord he already was despite
unit's slowing down on time the king and
the guardian were at a stalemate time
that was it the Scarlet King needed more
time withdrawing from the fight he
realized that this was a battle that
could not be won by sheer Brute Force
alone his mission to destroy all
creation to get to the tree of life
would take cunning deception and more
time if he let it the gate Guardian
could easily kill Contra its flaming
weapon could cleave him out of existence
and that would end the king's torment
but it wouldn't be enough a death would
be unsatisfying knowing that the rest of
existence would go on after he was gone
the Scarlet King couldn't accept that it
wasn't enough so he did the one thing
nobody would expect of him he made a
deal with the gate Guardian it was an
action still fueled by his infinite
hatred for all existence his yearning
for total chaos the Scarlet King knew
that one day an event would arrive where
the guardian and the other beings like
it in the Garden of Eden would spill
forth and deliver judgment on this world
and when that Rapture happened the tree
of life would be undefended the Scarlet
King Bartered with the guardian that he
would Retreat for the time being so he
could spend eon's amassing more and more
power then when the fateful day arrived
the gate Guardian would allow him into
Eden to destroy the Tree of Life while
it and its Brethren were busy conducting
ing the Rapture halting their fight the
Scarlet King offered a crimson claw to
the gate guardian's burning hand
returning to reality from the intense
Vision still feeling sick at what he had
witnessed Robert monok looked up at the
still silent form of the gate Guardian
did you do it he yelled desperate to
know more through his obsession with the
Scarlet King did you tell him yes did
you make a deal it was no answer from
the guardian just a single word that
echoed through monto's fractured mind
the SCP foundation's existence might be
a frightening thing to some but if you
ask us it's comforting of course the
existence of the foundation implies the
existence of all the Mind meltingly
terrifying entities they Combat on a
daily basis but doesn't it put your mind
at least a little at ease to know
somebody out there knows what's going on
after all sometimes knowledge is the
only light we have in the darkness it is
Humanity's greatest strength to know
things and to act accordingly from
knowledge we can understand our enemies
and the threats they pose against us
from knowledge we can build sturdier
defenses from knowledge we can develop
the means to finally effectively strike
back and nobody among the ranks of
humanity has more knowledge than the SCP
Foundation so what happens when the
knowledge of the SCP Foundation fails us
what happens when a concept ccept eludes
even them a concept like say SCP
2317 an old wooden door that hides
within a truly terrible secret a secret
known by many as the Devourer of Worlds
a beast every bit as powerful and
unpleasant as that name suggests the SCP
Foundation performs a complex set of
rituals every single day to keep him
contained and if the top Rass of the
foundation is to be believed then these
rituals are effective but I think we all
know better than to believe everything
we're told around here don't we the
truth is beyond the wooden door known as
SCP 2317 there is a hellish desert World
underneath which the Devourer of Worlds
awaits he is kept in place Bound by
ancient chains created by a race that
has long since been lost to the history
books and while the foundation tells its
underlings that the rituals d-class
Personnel perform here every day helps
to keep these chains in place this is
little more than a placebo the rituals
only exist to make the foundation feel
like they're doing something to buy time
while they figure out an actual lasting
solution in reality based on the
foundation's current knowledge These
Chains could break any day now and sadly
there's nothing they can do about it
this may seem like the worst possible
truth to learn but we can think of one
even worse truth that any day now is
today when the chain breaks the ground
begins to rumble worldwide Like An
Earthquake so great it might even split
the planet in two no conventional
scientist anywhere in the world has any
idea what's happening but the SCP
Foundation does for the first time in
recorded history the entire 05 Council
are quaking it's Judgment Day and there
every sin is on an Express trip back to
get them they put out a call to dispatch
every single mobile task force worldwide
to come to site 19 and combat this new
threat but deep down the council members
silently worried that this would be
about as effective as the Sham rituals
they claimed every day would protect
them meanwhile site 19 exploded most of
the foundation personnel and anomalies
stationed there perished in an instant
as a giant clawed hand rose out of the
ground grasping at the sunlight for the
first time in millions of years since
imprisonment it shear size hundreds of
kilometers in height displaces and
destroys the land around it as it climbs
free from the earth the devour of Worlds
is a monster of such magnitude that it
dwarfs even the foundation's mightiest
weapons but their mobile task Forces
fight valiantly or perhaps foolishly
nonetheless the foundation went in with
its finest resources and weaponry from
Advanced cruise missiles to classified
laser projectile weapons that
conventional militaries wouldn't be
finding for for another century and all
of it amounted to be the strength of
getting a mid- rate birthday Clown's
cheap cream pie to the face the thick
scaly hide of the Beast somehow rejected
everything they threw at it Jets were
scrambled flying around the devourers
gargantuan head and preppering its great
eye with bullets followed by heat guided
Rockets nothing the monster simply
swatted them out of the air with its
claws down below ground forces mobilized
on Mass from tanks to turrets un
leashing all kinds of Hell onto the
devour of Worlds from below and still
what good did it do the monster simply
kept walking killing thousands with
every footfall its magnitude was simply
unfathomable Scranton reality anchors
were placed at its feet in hopes of
creating some kind of trap but its
ancient feet defied their Force every
mobile task force from hammer down to
samsara did what they could and what
they could do ultimately amounted to a
fat lot of nothing the Rampage of the
Devourer was undeterred within an hour
he would reach a population Center and
then true hell would be Unleashed upon
the human race but sometimes the only
thing that could destroy something
inhuman was something so much more than
human over in the lowrisk humanoid
containment center of site 17 SCP 343
perhaps better known as God was watching
all the horror unfold in his Mind's Eye
so the Devourer was finally free and
Wrecking havoc on the world that he puts
so much effort into creating no no that
simply would not do how could he let
such a vulgar creature taking billions
of years of beauty love kindness
happiness and natural majesty and turn
it all into Ash and dust he would not
stand for it but God while unimaginably
powerful is a philosopher not a warrior
it would be not only beneath his
Celestial position but dangerous for all
life on Earth if he were to Unleash the
Power required to destroy the Devourer
himself the armies of God are the
greatest in heaven or Earth but he would
need a champion to lead them and while
the operatives of the SCP Foundation
fought and died bravely for the human
race SCP 343 blipped out of sight 17 and
reappeared in the Middle East where his
Champion would be waiting guarding the
gate to Paradise SCP 001 in this case
known as the gate Guardian a huge
glowing humanoid with wings made of fire
and a sword hotter than the sun capable
of cleaving its enemies apart on the
atomic level typically any being who
traveled within a kilometer of the gate
Guardian would receive this treatment a
strike so powerful that in the aftermath
not even dust would remain but when SCP
343 appeared meere feet away from the
mighty gate Guardian the guardian fell
to one knee and bowed its glowing head
in holy reverence master the guardian
said you have returned to me at long
last I will do thy bidding what must be
done Uriel God said Gravely an enemy is
at the gates one more powerful than this
world has ever known battle him while I
gather the armies do whatever it takes
he must be stopped the gate Guardian
Uriel Rose to his feet spreading his
great Wings of Fire it shall be done my
Lord
Uriel boomed and faster than any human
being could possibly perceive it he had
taken off into the sky leaving the gate
behind him unguarded for the first time
in the memory of the human race God side
it was time to finally open it back with
the devour and the mobile Task Force
Army trying in vain to slow his advance
for the most part the creature's hide
was so thick it was hard to even know if
he noticed most of the puny humans
firing on it some of the ones down below
below driven half mad with fear rage and
the crushing weight of futility pulled
out knives swords and bayonets and ran
at the creature's feet stabbing away
even as their blades were blunted and
destroyed of course the devour of Worlds
paid no mind to them it had something
else in its sights a human City a mere
handful of steps away yes yes so teeming
with life such delicious morsels the
Devourer would live up to his terrifying
namesake and feast on the all yes yes it
would be delicious as he crushed further
thousands of mobile task force soldiers
below him just by walking he could
hardly wait down below things had never
seemed so hopeless was this how it ended
one impotent Last Stand as a hungry
monster of inconceivable size bulldozed
through life and civilization and left
nothing nobody in its wake was this how
the complicated but proud story of the
human race would come to an end down
here in the worthless blood soaked mud
that's when something changed the sky
once blotted out with a Devourer Shadow
was lit up by a brilliant white light a
light so dazzling so holy and pure that
it gave even the Devourer pause the
human beings down below wept with joy
and numinous awe it was him it was SCP
001 the gate Guardian spreading his
fiery wings and drawing his solar sword
my master ordered me to destroy you his
deafening psychic voice boomed and thus
you shall be destroyed prepare to meet
your
maker the devour immediately let out a
world shaking Roar so powerful that many
of the humans down below felt their
brains rattling and their ears literally
beginning to bleed the Beast reached for
Uriel with its huge clawed hand moving
at impossible speeds for a creature at
size onlookers gasped in shock luckily
for as surprisingly fast as the devour
of Worlds was Uriel was faster like a
flash of an exploding light bulb the
guardian darted out of the devour palm
and cleaved a glowing gash into the
monster's wrist with his solar sword the
creature growled taken off guard it was
the first time in millions of years
since it was attacked and bound by those
impossible Celestial armies that it had
felt pain what was is this mysterious
Warrior of fire all the Devourer knew
was that if it wanted to turn the planet
Earth into an all you can eat buffet it
would need to do away with this glowing
nuisance first
die the psychic voice of the gate
Guardian commanded as it flew in for
another strike this time cleaving into
the beast's torso and leaving a long
glowing scar but he didn't stop there
the gate Guardian had changed posture
from a defensive territorial stance to
an allout offensive war path as
commanded by his all powerful Master
Uriel was not arrogant he could see that
the Beast he was battling was undeniably
formidable but he had slain formidable
enemies before and he would do so again
now taking advantage of the comparative
slowness and clunkiness of the Devourer
a natural side effect of its truly
immense size Uriel decided to stay
mobile flying around the devour like an
electron orbiting the nucleus of an atom
at any moment that he with his Warrior's
judgment detected an opening a weakness
he flew in and struck with extreme Fury
leaving another glowing scar in the
monster's thick scales that fizzled with
the impossible heat of his sword each
time the Beast gave a grunt or a growl
in confused pain as it desperately
flailed to try and grab the holy Warrior
meanwhile the SCP Foundation had figured
out what was happening and was
reorienting its focus while the gate
Guardian fought against and distracted
the devour of Worlds all surviving found
Foundation Personnel under the
instruction of the 05 Council converged
on the nearest city to the devour they
would evacuate as many as they could
buying them more time to calculate some
kind of meaningful counter offensive to
this XK Class end of the world scenario
if this really could be Humanity's Last
Stand they would go out swinging and
leave their opponent with a black eye
while the evacuation efforts were
underway yuriel continued his Relentless
assault against the Devourer carving
scar after scar into the monster's body
he could not tell if he was leaving much
lasting damage but at the very least he
was getting the Abominations attention
after striking its body countless times
though yurio finally felt bold enough to
go against the creature's obvious weak
point its huge staring cycloptic eye
perhaps with a decisive strike he could
blind the Beast faster than the speed of
sound Uriel orbited the beast's body and
reoriented himself in front of its eye
he could feel the n n seconds passing as
he charged raising his sword now would
be the time to end this but wait what's
that why is the devours eyes suddenly
glowing red before even Uriel had time
to react a tremendous force of pure
energy blasted forth from the devours
eye bombarding the Angelic Soldier and
firing him straight into the ground
below he did not even know the monster
possessed such a power and now the force
of it was hammering him into the Earth
the blast kept going for a few more
seconds zapping strength and introducing
him to a long forgotten pain when the
beam was done firing Uriel felt as
though he could barely move he was a
Sitting Duck that's when the devour
began marching towards him every step
rattling the Earth even as the threat
loomed Uriel couldn't move was this the
end forgive me master Uriel said I have
failed you then Uriel notice something
several projectiles firing towards the
devour head seemingly out of thin air a
volley of intercontinental ballistic
missiles each equipped with a nuclear
payload exploded against the creature's
head blasting it with a shock wave that
rattled the mighty creature on its feet
had human beings made such weapons if
they could still fight even after all
this Uriel thought then I must fight too
I must fight to my last breath as the
devour steadied itself recovering from
the nuclear bombardment to the Head
Uriel rose with a terrifying Warrior
Roar feeling his holy power returned to
him his sword ignited and he charged
forward faster than ever before ready to
strike clear and true into the Devourer
wretched heart before the Beast could
react Uriel shoved his sword into the
center of its chest causing veins of
agonizing flame to spread out over its
whole body at long last he had well and
truly harmed the unharmful that
knowledge Sanctified him even as the
devour of Worlds grabbed Uriel in his
Fist and squeezed the life out of the
warrior for God for the last time God
the Devourer thought in its own way I
can finally carry on now you fought
bravely Uriel said a booming voice from
above the Beast your sacrifice will not
be in vain that much I promise you
confused the devour turned and looked
Skyward only to see a sight that struck
pure and undiluted awe into even him it
was God and his army SCP 343 floated in
the sky lightning emanating from his
very being around him glowing Angelic
Warriors each as large and as powerful
as yuel and as numerous as the stars in
the sky above God pointed at the
Devourer now my children he said take
that thing apart from me want an anomaly
of your own check out SCP swag.com for
highquality SCP merch the SCP Foundation
works works very hard to keep all the
knowledge and evidence of their
discoveries from reaching the outside
world as far as the average person is
concerned the entities and anomalies
documented by the SCP Foundation do not
exist anyone that stumbles upon an
anomaly without authorization will wind
up having their memory wiped with
amnestics or something far far worse but
either way the knowledge never enters
into the general Public's Consciousness
but what if there was an anomaly that
even and the members of the foundation
didn't know about not because they
hadn't discovered it yet but because
somehow it wouldn't let itself be known
it sounds impossible but one particular
Foundation researcher faced this Paradox
while covering an anomaly that is
currently listed in the archives without
a number referred only as knife Junior
researcher Harris was assigned to SCP
4955 one day and given the
responsibility of examining it and
cataloging any anomalous Behavior
displayed by the item SCP 4955 was a
simple knife of unknown make and model
about the size and sharpness of a common
kitchen knife he took the knife into the
lab and ran the usual tests he scanned
the materials tested for any kind of
radiation administered thermodynamic
tests and did everything else that is
standard procedure for a new SCP in
spite of all of his efforts he found
nothing unusual about it at all it was
just a knife with a metal blade and a
wooden handle it didn't give off radi
ation it didn't have any unusual level
of sharpness it didn't glow in the dark
by all accounts it was a completely
ordinary boring knife so why then was it
even at the foundation in the first
place why was his time which could be
better spent on other more pressing
research being wasted here junior
researcher Harris decided to present his
highly uneventful report to his
supervisor it was then finally that the
strangeness began at the start of the
meeting Harris's supervisor had no
memory of anything being placed in
p0055 where the knife was being stored
Harris confirmed that yes there was
something there he continued his report
explaining that the knife had displayed
no anomalous properties at all and
didn't seem like the sort of thing the
foundation should be wasting resources
on as soon as he delivered his report
his supervisor just stared at him
blankly as if she was expecting
something from him unsettled Harris
asked her if she was all right she
replied sharply saying that she was
perfectly fine but was getting tired of
waiting for him to give his report
caught completely off guard Harris gave
her his report on the knife a second
time only to be met with the same Blank
Stare he attempted to give the report
two more times before giving up and
leaving in exasperation somehow as soon
as he told his supervisor about the
knife she forgot everything he said on
the subject determined to explore this
bizarre turn of events further Harris
set about recruiting a colleague to help
him conduct an experiment with the knife
he managed to bribe another found
Foundation employee named researcher
Smalls with $5 and the appeal of an
unsolved mystery and he agreed to step
in and participate as soon as Smalls
entered the room where the research was
being conducted Harris held up the knife
and showed it to him he asked Smalls do
you see this to which Smalls replied
bafflingly see what Harris approached
Smalls holding the knife right up to his
face still Smalls insisted that he saw
nothing in the room aside from Harris
and himself the more Harris pressed him
the more Smalls ins Ed with a smile that
he did not see the knife and had no idea
what Harris was talking about in a
frustrated Outburst Harris smacked
Smalls across the face with the broad
side of the knife he stumbled for a
moment as the blow made its impact then
steadied himself and looked at Harris
with the same expression as before the
same expression he had seen on his
supervisor earlier that same day
attempting to regain his composure
Harris asked Smalls did you feel that
Smalls grinned at him and replied all I
feel is Bored determined to pushed the
limits of his colleagues apparent
forgetfulness Harris cornered Smalls and
raised the knife to his face once more
this time slowly maintaining eye contact
with him all the while Harris used the
blade to make a deliberate shallow cut
across smalls's cheek the man winced as
the knife made its mark But as soon as
the blade was tucked into Harris's
pocket and out of sight he did not
reference it once he smirked at Harris
with blood dripping down his cheek from
a wound he would not acknowledge this
experiment with Smalls brought Harris
understanding of the knife into sharp
perspective the knife itself was not the
anomaly but rather the knife's effect on
anyone who observed it everyone with the
inexplicable exception of Harris who
observed or learned about the knife was
rendered somehow unable to verbally
acknowledge or possibly even comprehend
its existence Harris and Smalls met for
dinner later that evening and Harris was
fascinated to see that his colleague's
cheek was still smeared with blood it
had been left to dry there all day
undisturbed on small his face several
other researchers noticed the wound and
asked Smalls about it who insisted it
was nothing the Curious parties accepted
his answer but only after looking at
Harris for a long time though they would
not say it out loud on some level they
knew what had happened with the knife
when Smalls wasn't looking Harris dosed
his drink with a strong memory Recovery
Agent developed by the foundation's
antimemetics team and attempted to
introduce Smalls to the knife again
unfortunately it had no effect and
Smalls was still unable to acknowledge
the existence of the knife the next day
determined to take his experimentation
to the next level Harris cut his own
Chic with a knife he walked around the
facility as usual letting his wound
bleed freely onto his face and formerly
pristine white lab coat colleagues
stopped him to ask what had happened and
he told them plainly I cut myself with
SCP
4955 upon hearing those words each
person asking about Harris's injury
immediately turned and walked away
covering their mouth believing the knife
to be some kind of anti-em or an anomaly
that resists being recorded or
remembered Harris administered further
tests he ran the knife through a q&m
anti-em machine but found nothing the
knife behaved like previous anti-memes
but was unaffected by Machinery designed
to observe them and was immune to the
effects of memory recovery agents
designed to counter them what then was
it Harris was beginning to feel like he
was at the center of a grand practical
joke and he couldn't figure out the
punch line
all he knew was that his grip on reality
was beginning to slip and the knife was
to blame Harris's supervisor stopped by
his office to check in with him about
SCP
4955 demanding a report on the anomaly
at the end of his rope he responded what
4955 just as the supervisor began to
reprimand him for his poor attitude
Harris took the paperwork for 4955 and
shredded it into ribbons with a knife as
his supervisor watched as soon as he was
finished he looked up to see his his
supervisor staring at him wide eyy
slowly she lifted her hand to her mouth
and began to laugh she laughed loudly
uously like it was the best joke she had
ever heard then she asked him to take a
look at SCP 3309 instead Harris clenched
his jaw glared at her and lifted the
knife to his hand he sliced open the tip
of his finger and flicked the blood onto
her face she didn't even Flinch instead
she turned away laughing face still
streak with Harris's blood and went
about the rest of her day this is the
moment when Harris began to crack all he
wanted was for someone anyone to
acknowledge the knife that was driving
him out of his mind it was as if the
entire facility including his own
Machinery was gaslighting him he decided
to take more Extreme Measures to get
everybody's attention at this point
whatever it took he would do it Harris
marched into the foundation's cafeteria
at lunchtime carrying his usual bag he
walked into the center of the room
taking in the sight of his colleagues
his supervisor still had his blood on
her face small still had a pool of dried
blood on his cheek from his day old
wound Harris took a deep breath and
unzipped his bag pulling out a test rat
from one of the Laboratories as the
crowded cafeteria looked on Harris
pulled the knife from his pocket and
dispatched the rat with one quick slash
he held the dead rat up in the air
commanding the attention of the room
then let it drop with a sickening THB
no one said a word they only watched and
quietly laughed amongst themselves 5
days later the Wrath was still there it
had been stepped on and flattened by
days of foot traffic flies were
beginning to buzz around the corpse and
the smell had seeped into the ceiling
and walls still no one mentioned or
referenced it no one moved it and no one
talked about the knife the following day
unable to stand the smell or the sight
of it anymore Harris broke down and
cleaned up the rat as he did he could
hear people laughing behind him every
time Harris entered a room people were
laughing about something and no one
would tell him what still when he
brought up the knife even when he
screamed and cried and pleaded everyone
ignored the subject it would not and
could not be spoken about several days
later Smalls complained that someone had
cut the plants he was growing in his
room even though Harris had not cut his
plants he decided to take credit I did
it with my knife he said as soon as the
knife was mentioned small sat down and
went completely silent abandoning the
subject entirely this gave Harris
another crucial piece of information on
the nature of the knife's effects it did
not matter whether the knife was
actually present or involved in
something all that mattered was the
perception that it was even the mention
of the knife was enough to invoke its
effect the days bled into each other day
after day of Harris begging his
colleagues to see what he saw demanding
to know what the hell they were laughing
about and feeling more and more utterly
alone Harris's mind had truly begun to
come apart at the seams in the second to
last entry in his research log he simply
wrote it's almost Showtime time to give
the people what they want the day after
he wrote that cryptic entry Harris
walked up to Smalls in the cafeteria and
tapped him on the shoulder when Smalls
turned to greet his friend Harris
stabbed him in the chest Smalls fell to
the ground curling up in the fetal
position and Harris kicked the knife
deeper in as Smalls cowered there he did
not stop until Smalls was dead Harris
was removed from the facility leaving
the knife in smalls's body Harris was
promptly terminated eliminating the last
person who appeared was able to discuss
the knife as for the knife now its
current location is unknown making this
mundane little object one of the
greatest Unsolved Mysteries of the SCP
Foundation what was the knife exactly
what gave it such a strange hold on
people in the end it might not even
matter after after all what is more
frightening an object that prevents
people from being able to remember it or
being the only person in the whole world
who dies a pickaxe shatters the rocky
wall of a Min shaft hundreds of feet
below the Earth it's 1871 in a place
that will later be known as Columbia
County Pennsylvania men performing
backbreaking labor their hands and faces
blackened with dirt all working in
pursuit of that immensely valuable Rock
Coal it's the fuel for the booming
Industrial Revolution and much like how
dragons were said to guard gold this
more modern treasure pointed to an even
more terrifying monster a monster that
the SCP Foundation would someday come to
know as SCP
1179 but these unfortunate and underpaid
miners had no idea what they were about
to discover one of the men working there
that day Robo DWI was hammering away at
the wall in front of him when he heard
something strange was that an echo
behind the Rocks this could mean only
one thing the rocks in front of them
were Hollow there had to be some kind of
space hiding behind them owire struck
again and again at the Rocks in front of
him until the barrier finally tumbled
away he and the other miners suddenly
felt a gust of cool ancient air from the
vast and darkened Cavern in front of
them sweep through the mind they felt
like they were standing on the edge of
something truly otherworldly as they
lifted their safety lamps high and crept
carefully into the dark it dawned on
them that they were likely the first
human beings to ever set foot here but
that didn't mean something nonhuman
hadn't gotten there first odo's lamp
soon found something in the dark a huge
figure curled into a crouching position
hiding its face it was made from Stone
like an enormous yet incredibly detailed
statue of something Almost Human but not
quite the Petrified thing had two great
horns on either side of its head
twisting into spirals like that of a
huge RAM word of the giant Frozen
Monster hidden in the bottom of the Mind
soon made its way back to the foreman
and then back to the mind's owner one
Shan om Ali if it were anyone else
perhaps this news would have been taken
to the Press immediately and the
foundation would have taken control of
the situation just as quickly but Mr om
Ali was no ordinary mining magnet he was
a member of the Molly magu an Irish
American secret society whose members
were predominant coal miners in
Pennsylvania Shawn and the other Molly
Maguire dubbed this anomaly the sleeping
Stone Giant and conspired to keep it a
secret between them as secret societies
have a habit of doing though the Molly
magui were disbanded less than a decade
later they were all sworn to secrecy on
the Giant's resting place until of
course a descendant of sha Ali his
grandson Ian Al was chosen as a
prospective agent of the SCP Foundation
the foundation doesn't just let anyone
join their ranks they perform an
extensive background check on all
prospective agents both to find out that
they're capable of rising to the
challenges of the job and also to detect
any affiliation to enemy groups of
Interest it was during this background
check that omali Subterranean Family
secret was discovered and the land above
the old Min shaft was bought up by a
front company owned by the foundation
the sleeping Stone Giant was finally in
capable hands and in keeping with
standard procedure a research site was
built above the giant to gather data and
keep an eye on things at the time the
anomaly was considered extremely low
risk its containment file read SCP 1179
is apparently dormant encased in the
Bedrock under research site apart from
simple monitoring in standard research
safety protocols no additional
containment is deemed necessary at this
time but of course those simple
containment procedures would soon need
updating in 1962 the town of Centralia
Pennsylvania had a trash problem there
were eight illegal trash dumping sites
across the town and to combat this issue
the Town Council opened up a huge
landfill in an abandoned Min shaft you'd
think this would be enough for the
moderately sized town but humans have a
tendency to produce a lot of trash and
they soon filled up the new landfill too
in order to address the issue the town
decided to do a controlled burn of some
of the garbage it should have been
simple enough but those who lit this
garbage fire didn't follow proper safety
procedures and ended up accidentally
igniting a seam of anthr site coal this
was like lighting the fuse to the
world's largest stick of dynamite and
fire soon coursed through the long
abandoned mine tunnels when the fireball
finally reached the sleeping Stone Giant
in his dark pit the Beast woke up in
that instant an otherwise uneventful day
quickly became a brutal blood bath
researchers walking through the base
felt a monstrous rumbling beneath them
heat sensors were burning up and seismic
readings were off the scale something
was climbing up towards them suddenly an
impossibly large sword speared its way
out of the floor killing everyone around
it with an immense blast of heat the
newly awakened monster went on an
underground Rampage almost completely
destroying the research base and killing
nearly everyone inside before retreating
into the honeycomb of coal mines and
caverns in the area igniting even more
anthros site coal fires the foundation
needed to step step in before things
really got out of control at present the
foundation couldn't properly administer
standard area construction protocols for
ker class s scps so they instead
designated the mines caverns and
surrounding Countryside as area 179 and
dispatched mobile task forces to try and
contain the Beast rampaging in the
Centralia mines but much like the fire
that started this whole mess the Beast
proved much harder to control than
initially imagined all five of the
expeditionary teams sent to apprehend
the monster failed and many team members
were slaughtered in the process from the
terrifying accounts of the survivors we
have a vague idea of the nature of the
Beast below no pictures of the creature
exist and exact descriptions on the
Beast can vary whether this is because
the Beast frequently shape shifts or
because it has some kind of Cognito
hazardous effects on those who view it
is unclear the most frequently reported
characteristics of the creature are its
immense height and the extreme heat that
its body exudes many report that the
creature's body seemed to be formed of a
mix of hardened lava pure fire and
burning smoke the Beast measures over 30
m from head to toe with shoulders over 8
m wide it's commonly said to have two
huge ram-like horns and a weathered
bearded face the Beast has been compared
by some to the Norse mythological figure
CER the giant guarding the frontier of
the Norse fire realm of moose Bell
however the actual age of the creature
seems to predate these Legends by a
considerable margin dating of the
stratum Inc casing as CP 1179 indicates
it dates to the Mississippian sub period
of the Carboniferous period
approximately 359.06
million years ago this age is consistent
with the geological age of this region
so it may have literally come with the
territory less common descriptions of
the Beast claim that it has huge Wings
eyes made of Hellfire and fangs as long
as a man's arm some say that the Beast
has neither horns nor fangs and its face
is encircled By Flames which reach down
into a long beard of fire and like a
certain creature known as the ballog
that Lord of the Rings fans will be very
familiar with this Beast comes with
weapons in one hand the Beast wields a
giant burning sword around 5 m in length
in the other it wields a huge multitail
Whip made out of fire it's incredibly
proficient with these weapons too and as
a serious strategic IC advantage in its
underground environment Foundation
researchers have determined that some of
the wounds the Beast gained from its
first confrontation haven't fully healed
implying the Beast could in theory be
destroyed with enough Firepower however
given that the Beast has killed almost
everyone who faced it and its mere
presence can start almost uncontrollable
fires direct engagement would only be
used as a last resort even the
creature's breath can be extremely
dangerous chemical analysis of air
samples taken from SCP 1179 breath have
shown exceptionally high concentrations
of carbon monoxide and sulfur dioxide
the very presence of this creature
creates a real and active danger to
everyone around it and the Beast
presence was beginning to have seriously
negative effects on the people up above
by the 1970s the foundation had given up
on sending mobile task forces into the
caverns and instead began to focus on
depopulating the town of Centralia to
prevent further fatalities from the
presence of SCP
1179 the Subterranean activities of the
creature were causing collapses in some
areas and noxious fumes were beginning
to Rise Up from cracks in the ground as
the constant raging fires burned beneath
the Earth they were causing everything
above to slowly melt or bake a
foundation geologist determined that the
fires created by the Beast would likely
remain active for 250 years and any
attempts to put out the fires or contain
the Beast would ultimately be fule
this led to the formation of project
Tartarus a concerted effort to cover up
SCP 1179 and fully Evacuate the citizens
of Centralia they pushed the narrative
that the mine fires while deadly were
merely the result of the failed garbage
burning plan and little by little the
people of Centralia began to move away
by 1984 the United States government
finally Cav to secret lobbying from the
foundation and allocated funds in excess
of $42 million to relocate the remaining
C civilian residents from the area any
legal complaints from Centralia
residents were quietly crushed by the
foundation and efforts to remove pretty
much all residents from the area were
successful this allowed the foundation
to finally cast a wider net and
administer ker class containment
protocols around the 2 km underground
Zone where SCP 1179 resides the
foundation has continued studies on the
bees from Below in the decade since with
some scientists even suggesting it could
be used to produce G geothermal energy
but whether or not that would actually
be feasible remains unknown for now SCP
1179 seems content to stay within its
Zone and hopefully it stays that way but
as we're forced to dig deeper and deeper
for the remaining precious metals here
on Earth there's no telling what new
dangers we might find lurking far below
the ground the military helicopter
sailed through the skies at a steady
Pace its destination somewhere in
Southwest Asia Asia along one of the
many points where the legendary
Euphrates and Tigress rivers meet
depending on the outcome this mission
may have changed the course of the SCP
Foundation and its activities forever or
it might do nothing at all such was
often the way when it came to dealing
with the unpredictable and the anomalous
inside the helicopter Dr Anton zarov was
practically rattling with nervous
excitement ever since he'd been assigned
to the 682 termination d
after years of wasting away in an
archival desk job he'd seen the kind of
anomalies you wouldn't believe 173 that
nightmarish statue that snaps the necks
of anyone who dared to look away from it
811 the strange and also strangely
adorable swamp woman whose costic mucus
could reliably melt seemingly any
organic matter save of course 682 itself
and Dr zarov was particularly astonished
by the aftermath of the epic battle
between 096 and 682 which left both of
these indestructible monsters horribly
maimed but all of that it was nothing
compared to what they were going to
witness today Dr zarov muttered a prayer
to himself in frightened reverence Dr
cleff Who was sitting across from him
and the helicopter wasn't quite as wound
up like some action movie cliche made
manifest he sliced chunks from a plump
red apple with a Bowie knife and sucked
the pieces off the blade clef found
zarov nervousness little more than
amusing first time at sight zero rookie
klef asked between apple slices Dr zarov
nodded forcing a Meek smile klef just
chuckled H you're wasting your time you
know klef said everyone takes a shot at
the reptile I face it down myself once
mono imano and during that moment I
realized something as much as it pains
me to ever throw in the towel we're not
going to kill this thing it's just a
budget syn of course these kinds of
doubts had crossed Dr zarov mind before
he'd watch countless termination
attempts organized by far more senior
researchers than himself fail and fail
embarrassingly something about signing
your name up for 682 termination was
like tying on a blindfold grabbing a bat
and stepping up to a Piata except in
this case the Pata isn't wearing a
blindfold and somehow it can hit you
back it is a one-way ticket to
professional humiliation and if you're
unlucky enough to get too close when
things go south it can be so much worse
but Dr zarov well and truly believed
that he would be the exception to so
much miserable failure after all this
was an idea nobody had tried before an
announcement over the intercom signaled
that they had now entered site zero
airspace they'd be landing shortly and
just like that Dr zarov was all raised
hairs and Goose flesh once again it
seemed like such a hazy distant miracle
that his project proposal would even get
majority approval from the 05 Council
and now he was about to touch down and
actually see it naturally Dr cleff
noticed Dr zarov emotional cues and like
so many playground bullies decided to
seize on it don't buy into the hype Dr
kleff said it's really not that special
the helicopter touched down Dr zarov
felt defensive he was almost tempted to
use hard words but he realized from Dr
clef's mischievous smile that perhaps
that was always the intention he
certainly had a
reputation if one were to put it in the
most neutral terms possible but this was
your 001 proposal Dr cleff zarov
countered I would have thought you'd be
more invested in this Dr clef Rose to
his feet and sheathed his Bowie knife as
the helicopter's side door opened he
gestured for Dr zarov to get up and
follow him before saying believe me even
a giant flaming demigod loses its luster
when you need to write enough of those
stupid reports on it the two research
ERS disembarked from the helicopter and
walked into the legendary containment
facility site zero one of the most
important and secretive containment
sites out there even by the standards of
the ever clandestine SCP Foundation if
ever containment procedures failed here
they'd be staring down the barrel of an
unprecedented situation A Patmos XK
Class end of the world scenario after
all they were dealing with one of the
most serious and Powerful anomalies
they' ever contained here cleen zarov
entered the control room filled with
huge monitors displaying every kind of
recordable metric but the largest
screens were dominated by long range
Drone footage of the iconic anomaly they
were all there to see SCP 001 perhaps
better known as Uriel the gate Guardian
while Dr klef remained unfazed Dr zarov
felt a single tear crawling down his
cheek he had never seen an entity so
utterly on inspiring an impossibly tall
tall glowing humanoid entity with eight
great fiery wings and a glowing blade
made of pure Heavenly Fire every bit as
hot as the sun to think that such an
incredible creature existed on the same
Earth as him made him feel so incredibly
small the theories as to the creatures
true nature were as Myriad as they were
unknowable some of the more devout among
the foundations ranks even believe that
he is a direct servant of the abrahamic
god guarding the gate to Paradise the
Garden of Eden heaven
itself Dr clef just
laughed everything you'd hope it be
zarov he said Dr zarov nodded and more
Dr cleff and more even from such a
distance the raw power of the gate
Guardian is impossible to ignore it
radiates off of the being like an
invisible Aura Dr zarov had read all the
files to get within a kilometer of the
mighty entity would be to court death
anyone who approached it would taste the
heat of its sword cleave them apart at
the atomic level and effectively erasing
them from existence it's about as dead
as anyone could possibly be save for
someone being thrown into SCP 3930 and
literally removed from the plane of
existence SCP 3930 had failed to
annihilate the hard to destroy reptile
but perhaps where that whole lot of
nothing had failed the gate Guardian
would succeed it remained floating fixed
on one place as though waiting for
something but why perhaps a fateful
confrontation with a certain reptilian
nightmare Dr zarov hoped like many he
had heard the most famous story
involving SCP 001 the gate Guardian
which took place before even the days of
the SCP Foundation after all every
Foundation needs a Founder doesn't it
and that's how it began the founder was
a mysterious figure no matter who you
ask some say it was 05- one others say
it was the legendary administrator some
even believe that it was someone else
someone older someone who predated even
the current 05 Council and administrator
a wise and learn figure going on a
pilgrimage around the Known World in
hopes of expanding their perspective and
seeking out the strange and unusual it
was traveling down the river Tigress
that the founder encountered the gate
guardian of course as always from a mile
away the founder saw the distant glowing
Point shaped like a human being with
wings it was unlike anything they'd ever
born witness to that's when the founder
felt a door open in the back of their
mind and something sneak in a single
word projecting somehow infinite
Authority
prepare the very presence of the word
made the Founder's body rattle never had
they heard such a voice conveying such
certainty and power it had to be the
voice of the distant glowing figure it
couldn't be anything else could it much
like Dr zarov would experience hundreds
of years later the found founder even as
a person so powerful knowledgeable and
influential suddenly felt so
unimaginably small the founder became
aware of not just the extent of the
world around them or even the universe
but a terrifying Multiverse of
possibilities there was light out there
of course but even more darkness and
terrifying things were hiding in the
dark is that what prepare meant did it
mean to be ready for all the Terrible
Things hiding in the dark just waiting
for the opportunity to strike just how
great was the extent of the things
Humanity didn't understand out there the
Founder's mind was flooded with so many
possibilities if there was a tide of
monsters in the Blackness that needed to
be fought back it was too much for any
one person to ever handle the founder
needed a group all gathered around the
same mission to contain the coming
threat that the great glowing being had
warned them about people of focus
commitment and sheer willpower people
who would accept the knowledge of the
Terrible Things in the darkness and
still not waver in the face of their
great and Noble challenge people who if
necessary would be willing to die in the
dark so that the rest of the human race
would live in the light they would be
Humanity's greatest Defenders even
though they would defend in secret this
was how it had all begun supposedly Dr
zarov had heard the story whispered many
times while conducting his research into
SCP 001 and now here he stood perhaps
where the founder had been standing all
those years ago the SCP Foundation had
faced down greater threats than SCP 682
the hanged King the sealed King The
Scarlet King now if they wanted to they
could go toe-to-toe with the Burger King
and all of that had begun with a single
word from the mighty gate Guardian
surely an ordinary overgrown lizard
wouldn't be too much for it to handle
but of course they hadn't just come here
to look at the gate Guardian that'd be
an egregious waste of time and
helicopter fuel they'd come here
transporting Precious Cargo a chunk of
SCP 682s flesh cut from the Beast itself
currently it was attached to yet another
remote controlled drone set on a
collision course for the gate Guardian
Dr zarov watched the video feeds with
sweaty Palms as he saw the Drone and its
diabolical cargo enter the video's View
getting closer to the gate Guardian by
the moment Closer Closer until the gate
Guardian struck out with its great and
terrible sword for such an
astronomically huge being to move so
incredibly fast was astounding in and of
itself but what Dr zarov found even more
exciting was the result in one quick
slash of its solar blade both the Drone
and the SCP 682 tissue sample were
utterly evaporated gone reduced to less
than even Ash doctors sharov's face
split into a manic grin if it could
destroy the tissue sample then surely it
could destroy the monster itself and
what a glorious day that would be
Meanwhile Back At The Cross testing
chambers of site 19 SCP 682 was having
another miserable day it was dragged
half melted out of its acid tank at 3:00
a.m. in the morning and left slowly
regenerating on the floor a typical SCP
Foundation wakeup call it thought to
itself with the role of its still
regenerating eyes what form of horrible
torment would be in store for it this
time it began scrolling through its
mental Rolodex for the most recent
failed but painful termination attempts
oh yes of course they tried Suffocation
via vacuum that definitely made SCP 682
feel a little lightheaded at least until
of course it adapted its body to begin
releasing a gas of similar composition
to its native atmosphere which had
certainly given those white-coated
wearing ssts say lot to take note about
then how could it forget they tried
roasting it to death with extremely high
temperatures thankfully as always it had
a trick up its sleeve adapting a carrase
made of solid helium to defend it from
the fire then shattering it to shred a
bunch of those buffoons in the orange
jumpsuits then they'd cut off a sample
of its flesh shoved it into some absurd
industrial blender before shoving what's
left into a centrifuge what a Divine
pleasure it had been for 682 to hear the
explosion down the the hall when the
antimatter embedded in its genes went
off and put a number of those idiotic
Foundation drones in the hospital for
months SED them right to continually
meddling in the matters of forces they
couldn't even hope to understand and
today they were feeding at the carcass
of a dead cow SCP 682 side it felt
sometimes that adults testing it had
forgotten the note reading highly
intelligent on its file being dragged
into one of those Gastly Chambers and
given some form of Novel stimulus could
only mean one thing something stupid and
painful was going to happen said stupid
painful thing in this case was that the
cow was spiked with an instance of SCP
3521 also known as the banana Pill by D
What followed was a remarkably absurd
instance even by SCP 682 cross test
standards where a huge number of bananas
spontaneously burst out of 682s body
being a big fan of bananas apparently
682 was actually able to eat and
metabolize the bananas faster than the
anomalous banana Pill by dto could
produce them and because bananas are
each individually slightly radioactive
682 was able to synthesize this
Collective radiation into a powerful
death ray that it used to cause a great
deal of death and destruction as far as
Dr zarov and the rest of the SCP
Foundation were concerned this thing
being cleaved apart on an atomic level
by the gate Guardian couldn't come soon
enough sometimes it took the ultimate
Knight to SL play The Ultimate Dragon
not long after that SCP 682 was dosed up
on enough sedatives to give New York
City a weekl long nap and carted over to
sight zero on a heavily secured armored
Convoy taking SCP 682 this far between
containment sites was considered a
matter of grave seriousness in other
words the result of this little
experiment better have been good to
justify the insane security risk it took
to even get the damn lizard out here Dr
zarov and Dr decided to co-supervise the
Cross test from the safety of the sight
zero observation deck either would have
been foolish to want to get any closer
even Dr kle while undeniably a loose
cannon didn't have an outright Death
Wish unless of course wishing death on
SCP 682 would count 682 sedated body was
strapped to a large unmanned vehicle the
kind they might use for an exploratory
mission on another planet and sent in
the direction of the gate guardian's
deadly proximal Zone a secondary camera
drone was also sent in to lag behind
correctly predicting that when the gate
Guardian struck SCP 682 it would
obliterate the unmanned vehicle too and
whatever happened out there the
foundation needed it on camera Dr zarov
had sweaty palms and gritted teeth
seeing the culmination of his
professional career unfold in front of
him Dr cleff was looking at a meme on
his phone as 682 got closer it began
hearing a booming voice in its head just
like the founder had so long ago the
voice simply said one word over and over
getting louder as the unmanned vehicle
brought the two Titans closer and closer
and closer
die 682 still feeling groggy thought oh
if it only were so simple and then it
happened SCP 682 entered the dreaded 1
km range the guardian slashed down with
its mighty sword creating a brilliant
flash of light in the aftermath the
unmanned vehicle was obliterated and 682
was left heavily injured on the ground
still trying to process what had just
happened 682 looked up sobered by the
pain and saw the being that had dealt
this blow 682 began to sneer is this
meant to be the garden it said before
breaking into a venomous
laugh this is not the garden the garden
is far west of here
the gate Guardian struck again with its
flaming blade once again projecting that
single word die die die die die When the
Smoke cleared 682 was even more
horrifically injured with only one limb
left but still Against All Odds alive it
used the one limb to drag itself towards
the gate Guardian fueled by pure rage
and spite die you command me to die a
would we all like that but this is my
curse for suggesting the fruit the
reptile growled back at the base Dr
zarov was mortified how could it
possibly be surviving all this the sword
was meant to cleave apart its victims on
an atomic level Atomic it's in freaking
atams godamn it Dr zarov wish he had a
paper bag to breathe into Dr clef
showing an uncharacteristic degree of
compassion patted zarov on the back
saying it's okay buddy we all remember
our first time back at the center of the
action the gate Guardian blasted 682
with its solar blade again somehow
despite the terrifying power wielded by
the guardian 682 continued to live it
was alive barely but after three strikes
from The Sword to be alive with whatever
the evil version of a miracle would be
this is not the garden and you are not
yuel 682 roared before spitting at the
gate Gard Ian
Pretender one more violent strike from
the gate guardian and 682 finally
collapsed unconscious from the extent of
its pain and its injuries but despite
all of Dr zarov hopes the gate Guardian
did not strike a killing blow on the
unconscious Beast instead it transmitted
another word another order impossible
for any human being to ignore
remove as though in a trance the workers
of sight zero including Dr zarov and Dr
kleff entered the Forbidden 1 km
exclusion Zone the gate Guardian allowed
them safe passage as they used tools and
vehicles to pick up the heavily injured
SCP 682 and card it away from the gate
Guardians feet after they all came back
to their senses Dr zarov simply said
what just happened Dr cleff just
Shrugged I've learned to stop
questioning it day had broken and the
World As We Knew It fell to pieces on
every corner of the globe devastating
rays of sunshine have liquefied most of
the human race the anomalous phenomenon
known as SCP 001 had made the most
treasured source of light and life in
the Galaxy into the harbinger of a
planetary Apocalypse in the streets of
major cities which were once so filled
with culture and activity melting
Abominations slithered along the
sidewalks and pavement a cruel parody of
the crowds and traffic that existed in
the world before the drought ravage
Wilderness teams with countless Globs of
mutant flesh that were once proud
members of the animal kingdom even the
plants have wilted into an inert State
overwhelmed by the sun's energy to the
point of being unable to photosynthesize
it there are no planes in the sky
anymore as no pilot flying on that day
could escape the view of daylight the
boundless ocean is a drift with boats
and cruise laners occupied by an aim
crew of amalgamations which even the
initial survivors on the lower decks and
within the rooms have long since been
assimilated into in the early months of
SCP 0011 day breaks the foundation had
been able to distribute rudimentary
information on how to Shield oneself
from the perversive Rays this included a
basic but comprehensive how-to guide on
building protective clothing that would
keep out all daylight unfortunately
there was only so much benefit the
solution ions can provide as it has
become too late to save the vast
majority of humanity from their terrible
melting fate there are sadly limits on
what the foundation's foresight and
knowledge could do to prevent a worst
case scenario and many containment sites
were lost within the first 24 hours
alone this means that the veil of
normaly that the SCP Foundation had
fought so hard to preserve has
effectively ceased to exist most if not
all of the accumulated research the the
containment procedures for Dangerous
anomalies and the skilled Personnel who
were Brave and foolish to think they
could keep the world safe have met with
terrible Fates in this solar scarred
hellscape if there was ever an era where
the planet and the universe were stable
and under the control of the foundation
and the 05 Council that time has passed
this is not their world anymore nor is
it a world that can be ruled by any
people day has broken and this is the
world of monsters today two of these
monsters in particular find themselves
on a collision course both were once
extremely dangerous ker class scps
contained by the foundation but through
circumstance and Ingenuity both
anomalies had freed themselves and
adapted to the harsh new reality of the
outside world they were known as SCP
076-2 Abel and SCP 682 respectively Abel
now known in the the Fireside stories of
human survivors as the black Warrior had
given himself an armored makeover by
forging his many weapons into a day
prooof Second Skin straight out of Dark
Fantasy media this new edgy gothic look
came complete with a massive sword that
able could Ed to cleave straight through
any fleshy freak Show he encountered in
the Wasteland he was a true living
legend now a mysterious hero a violent
demon and a force of nature all at once
in the day he stock through the ruins of
civilization finding whatever passed for
worthy opponents and cutting them down
at night he would seek out those
depraved Souls would Prey Upon their
fellow human and put them to the sword
these malactor had recently become
Able's favorite Vermin to exterminate
since they always seemed so surprised to
be on the receiving end of an ambush
being a survivor in this hellish new
world was difficult enough without the
additional strain of plotting violence
so the ones who took advantage of the
absence of laws and did so were either
exceedingly clever or simply driven out
of their wits by the desire to inflict
harm it was through several experiences
stomping out the lingering scum of the
earth that Abel discovered an unfamiliar
sense of Honor within himself it wasn't
that he grew accustomed to protecting
frail humans from Monsters but rather
the simple fact that a good fight
required two mutually adversarial
parties Bandits and serial killers could
routinely be counted on to have delus
ions of grandeur accompanied by ill
intentions while their hapless victims
could not in his own Twisted way Abel
had accepted that showing Mercy to
cowards and weaklings suited his ends
after all if there were no more
Innocents Left Alive there would also be
no more reprobates to Menace them his
Quarry needed something to bait them
into emerging from the Shadows after all
despite having made the most of slim
picking there was a deep-seated part of
Abel that longed for a real challenge
the black Warrior wished to face a real
monster like himself again not the petty
brutes and former human sludge he'd been
using as substitutes 682 would be an
ideal opponent but he hadn't seen the
reptiles since he was back in
containment the two had been made to
fight each other the day before all of
this began and when during the ConEd
breach that later ensued 682 had a
makeover of its own the highly morphic
lizard had tunneled its way out of sight
19 by evolving large scho looping claws
suited for subterranean travel being
surprisingly intelligent for its
animalistic shape 682 had managed to
torture the details of the SCP 001
scenario out of an unlucky researcher
while Abel had found a way to remain
active during both day and night SCP 682
had become a bit more selective in its
schedule this was possibly because the
creature had adapted an internal clock
by absorbing the previously mentioned
researchers wristwatch while the sun was
was visible in the sky 682 would remain
dormant underground there it could bask
in the Symphony of suffering from all
the surfaced delling living things it
could perceive with its enhanced hearing
it would lie and wait for hours
anticipating the darkness of Nightfall
once the sun had set SCP 682 would
emerge and devour both human and
Abomination alike as a being that
harbored pure hatred for all things that
lived the reptile had far less
Discerning criteria for acceptable
targets than Abel it Unleashed its wrath
on anything that so much has got in its
way during the nightly Feeding Frenzy
another way that 682 differed from Abel
in its post-apocalyptic way of life was
that it hadn't been given any evocative
nickname or title the reason why was
surprisingly simple 682 hadn't made its
existence known because any survivors
that encountered it never Liv to tell
the tale it was a surprise to both of
them when late one night a Twist of f
fate brought the monsters back together
SC SCP 682 had just resurfaced near a
small encampment of survivors and was
approaching with the intention to
Massacre the panicking humans as the
hateful reptile Drew closer it noticed a
dark figure lurking at the other side of
the campfire it was roughly the size of
an average humanoid but instead of
running and screaming the figure stood
firm with an enormous sword in one hand
one of the fleeing humans cried out it's
the black Warrior we're saved this
amused 682 and it sported a sadistic
grin as it ran toward the Survivor and
pounced while the lizard had wanted to
demonstrate how flimsy the human sense
of Salvation really was the opposite
took place the so-called black Warrior
had intercepted its jaws and was
blocking 682 with only his sword and all
the Superhuman strength he could put
behind it go now little ant the black
Warrior said following Abel's command
the human fled looking back over over
its shoulder only once to gaze at the
black warrior in silent awe with that
straggler gone the two monsters were now
completely alone in the camp both
illuminated by the orange glow of Fire
Light they separated and began to Circle
each other memories of their old rivalry
began flooding back as both of the now
liberated ker classes confirmed the
identity of the other SCP 682 began to
laugh as it recognized The Stance of the
ancient warrior that had been such a
thorn in its side hied back in
containment isn't this Priceless the
proud and merciless AEL has become a
defender of those disgusting humans SCP
682 said wearing that horrible smile
once again I am not fighting for them
the black Warrior answered he lunged
forward striking a hard blow against
682s carapace the edge sword bounced
upward in Recoil but not without
inflicting a deep wound that 682s
regeneration began to work overtime to
repair the reptile swiped at Abel with
its scoop claws then made further use of
them by burrowing into the ground below
Abel knew better than to follow the
creature underground and he was almost
sure that his scaly Nemesis hadn't yet
retreated he held his ground and waited
stealing himself for the moment the
creature revealed itself once more as
expected the attack came from directly
below SCP 682 breached the surface and
snapped its jaws around one of Abel's
armored legs trusting his in SS the
black Warrior struck back in the same
moment his sword stabbed into the
reptile's jaws and with a bit of
strength he leveraged his own leg free
the armor was dented but fortunately
there was no apparent holes left by 682s
fangs AEL had become accustomed to
diligently maintaining the condition of
his armor as even the smallest crack
could in the daylight hours cause him to
lose his solid form forever he'd made
sure to do a more thorough investigation
later after the lizard had been put in
its place the black Warrior fought
defensively minimizing the damage to his
armor while timing his strikes to keep
682 from overwhelming him with sheer
offense he could certainly go all out if
he chose to but that same part of him
that wanted a challenge was willing to
prolong the conflict especially if he
could save himself the trouble of
repairs later SCP 682 on the other hand
didn't much care for being taken lightly
and was astute enough to notice when his
foe was n as aggressive as usual it had
been over a year since the monsters had
fought but this time there would be no
Foundation Personnel to end the fight
prematurely 682 decided it was time to
give the armored Edge Lord an onslaught
that he couldn't ignore it began to
rotate its tunneling claws like a pair
of pneumatic excavators and instantly
showered the black warrior with dirt and
debris as it burrowed back into the
Earth Abel could deflect the Rocks
easily enough but the temporary
distraction gave 682 time to dig a large
enough Cavern beneath Abel's feet that
the ground instantly collapsed beneath
his armored bulk Abel slid into the
growing pit and straight towards the
twin grinding claws of 682 he tried to
use his sword in the ground to slow his
descent but the Earth had been so
thoroughly tenderized by his opponent
that all he accomplished was hastening
it just like an ant lion larvae SCP 682
had created a Death Pit of detris that
was pulling Abel towards the center of
its CP as if making a Whirlpool on land
wasn't crazy enough for 682 the reptile
grew itself in a ray of impaling horns
across the front of its face and snout
though constructed of Flesh and Bone
they had the appearance of serrated
blades and possessed a sharpness and
durability capable of penetrating
through ael's fancy new suit of armor
but the black Warrior wasn't going to be
defeated so easily especially not after
all the work he had put in during his
latest life to forge these armaments
while clutching his giant blade in one
hand he conjured a new weapon from the
Shadows a harpoon with a strong chain
that appeared already wrapped tightly
around his black gauntlet Abel hurled
the Harpoon behind him with as much
strength as he could manage in his
nearly prone state and as he hoped its
tip embedded itself in the more stable
ground past the edge of the Death Pit
with the spear firmly secured at the
other end the chain went taau and Abel
was able to stop himself just short of
falling on
scp-682's facial Spike with a tremendous
one-handed swing that would be
impossible for a mortal man able cut
through the middle of the lizard's
organic bayonets rendering them
practically useless his metal boots dug
into the slit and with all his strength
he wrenched himself backwards towards
the top of the pit tearing the Harpoon
free in the process with acute Precision
he used the chain to direct the tip of
the Harpoon between the fractured bone
blades and into 682 skull the creature
bellowed from the sudden pain and began
to dig down downward again but by this
time Abel was on stable Earth again and
was pulling with all his strength on the
other side of the chain SCP 682 burrowed
as furiously as it could but the Harpoon
embedded in its head was throwing off
its equilibrium Abel planted his feet
and kept pulling summoning more weapons
around his feet and legs to keep them
from moving an inch back toward the pit
it was a Titan's tug of war and whoever
gave in would surely be at the mercy of
the other neither monster wavered and
the thing that broke Under The Strain
was the chain itself 682 tunneled away
Harpoon still scratching its brain and
did not surface again that night while
the black Warrior staggered as he
retrieved his now broken length of chain
Abel waited for his hated foe to
resurface but the creature had
apparently decided it was no longer
interested in a fight and it was just as
well because in the East the sun was
Rising again the black Warrior moved
inside one of the tents that the surviv
vivors had left behind and prepared for
a full examination of his armor while it
didn't last and no SCP save for SCP 001
could claim victory here Abel was
grateful to know there were still proper
adversaries to fight after the end
Fearless Relentless and one of the most
utterly brutal Warriors to ever walk the
face of the Earth with a body counts
somewhere in the high hundred thousands
if not well into multiple Millions given
just how long he's been around for many
of you will already be well aware of SCP
076-2 also known as AEL on the surface
he's a man of Middle Eastern descent
covered in tattoos of occultt symbols
and demonic faces usually contained
within a stone Cube designated as CP
0761 Abel will often emerge in a
homicidal State killing anyone and
anything directly around him how well by
any means available to him but primarily
by pulling a wide array of bladed
weapons seemingly out of thin air this
is thanks to a tiny pocket Dimension
that only he can reach into which is
also always stalked with an assortment
of deadly implements for his latest
murder spree as if being highly combat
proficient and always armed didn't make
him enough of an imposing threat SCP
076-2 also possesses a near superhuman
resistance to damage making him
incredibly difficult to take down and
even if someone is able to eventually
neutralize him Abel will also come back
resurrecting inside SCP
0761 to fight another day what you may
not know is for a Time AEL actually
worked alongside the SCP Foundation
although nowadays they prefer to keep
him locked away in a secure containment
facility underwater which they will
flood with seawater if he ever escapes
but AEL was once appointed the leader of
his own mobile task force Omega 7
referred to under the code name of
Pandora's Box you see the foundation
realized that SCP 076-2 held an
especially high regard for those who
proved well able to best him in combat
and it was this strange code of honor
that AEL held that the foundation hoped
to exploit with the creation of
Pandora's Box comprised of empty of
operatives that had earned Abel's
respect most by previously beating him
in a fair fight or as as Fair as a fight
with a man who can summon swords through
a tear in the fabric of reality can be
these agents would support Abel during
missions in the field during which the
SCP Foundation were able to deploy the
anomalous warrior in various tactical
engagements however this didn't last
long eventually Abel grew tired of
carrying out the orders of the
foundation The Immortal Warrior craved a
challenge Breaking Free of containment
and turning on the foundation resulting
in AEL being neutralized by an on-site
nuclear weapon this marked the end of
the fragile alliance between SCP 076-2
and the SCP Foundation leaving the
existence of Omega 7 a classified secret
and one of the organization's most
embarrassing missteps well but what if
that hadn't happened what if out there
in the infinite Multiverse there was a
world where Abel had been allowed to
remain a part of Omega 7 and the mobile
task force was never disbanded well
you're about to find out in our world
Able's dissatisfaction with being a
member of Pandora's Box first became
apparent when he began putting the rest
of his unit through live fire exercises
brutalizing his men despite these
exercises being intended as for training
purposes only but in this world the
injuries and even casualties AEL
inflicted on the rest of Omega 7 were
met with a much different response the
o5 Council of this alternate version of
the SCP Foundation viewed ael's
outbursts during training as acceptable
losses every time he would injure one of
Omega 7 the council would demand that
Replacements be on hand to become part
of the task force drawn from the ranks
of the other mtfs at their disposal
after all Abel was a valuable asset for
carrying out the foundation's Dirty Work
by continually replenishing his team
with reserves from their seemingly
inexhaustible supply of other MTF agents
the 05 Council of this world were able
to keep SCP 076-2 firmly under their
employ however it is also important to
note that Abel's patience for these new
recruits was far more limited than the
original Omega 7s those men had all been
handpicked by Abel personally and
appointed to the project given that he
had some modum of respect for them as
combatants whereas all of their
Replacements were plucked at random from
the foundation's other mtfs as a result
SCP 076-2 would carelessly kill or wound
more and more of these result reserves
during combat missions hardly
distinguishing between friend and foe
but despite this the 05 Council refused
to discontinue the Omega 7 project
viewing these as acceptable losses and
letting the success rate of ael's
missions justify the depletion of their
other mobile task forces under ael's
leadership and the command of the 05
Council Omega 7 would become the
foundation's primary rapid response unit
and the most deployed task force for
Dangerous field operations and working
for the foundation meant that every
field mission was a highly dangerous one
such was the case during one Containment
Breach where SCP 682 managed to get free
of a acid tank a rampaging infinitely
adaptable hard to destroy reptile on the
loose slaughtering all in its path was
bad enough but the 05 Council had
received Intel that there was something
more behind this breakout than it first
seemed and so Abel and the rest of his
latest Omega 7 team were sent in to
pacify SCP 682 bursting into the
facility eager to once again be freed
from containment and the monotonous
underwhelming experience of training
Abel flew into combat drawing black
swords from his personal Armory he began
to tear through everything and everyone
in his path unfortunately for the
foundation Personnel on site this also
meant they were subject to Able's
Relentless wrath as if running away from
SCP 682 wasn't B enough fleing research
staff were quickly met with the swing of
SCP 076-2 weapons and removed from the
premises in a brutal fashion still this
meant little to Abel and even less to
the 05 Council as far as they were
concerned even their own staff were just
collateral damage more acceptable losses
justified by ael's Perfect record for
successful high-risk High reward field
missions however that perfect record was
about to be tarnished for good you see
this containment breach wasn't your
average SCP 682 escape attempt it was
instead a situation that had been
meticulously planned and carried out for
one purpose this breach was intended
specifically to draw Abel out since he
had become the SCP foundation's primary
weapon and response to danger in the
field a particularly devious third party
had begun to take note the chaos
Insurgency a splinter faction that began
its life as an off the books Black Ops
unit for the foundation themselves had
been monitoring ael's deployment by the
05 Council in this universe their origin
was the same as in ours and the
Insurgency took a certain disdain to
seeing an anomalous individual carrying
out the kind of operations their group
had been formed to undertake for the
foundation Additionally the use of SCP
076-2 as a personal attack dog by the 05
council is hypocrisy the Insurgency
believed in the practical application of
anomalies rather than locking them up
and keep keeping them contained and it
was for this belief that they had been
vilified by the foundation and yet here
was the same organization sending AEL on
missions with no care for the harm he
caused and so as a result the chaos
Insurgency had conducted an operation to
break into the foundation free SCP 682
and send the hardto destroy reptile on a
rampage also they could take their shot
at able being ambushed by a group of C
Insurgency operatives on his way to
engage SCP 682 Abel was admittedly
caught by surprise but by now his combat
prow was second to almost nobody else in
the world the insurgents dog piled on
ail unleashing every ounce of Firepower
they had brought to bear on the immortal
Warrior the ensuing firefight destroyed
an entire wing of the foundation
facilities explosive weapons being
detonated in the hopes that the
Insurgency could subdue AEL all the
while SCP 076-2 shr Ed off the oncoming
damage catching rockets that were
launched at him and throwing them back
in the direction of the chaos insurgents
it was a bloodbath nearly the entire
Omega 7 team that had accompanied Abel
and provided him with fire support were
lying dead the same could also be said
for the insurgency's forces too though
with each of them being gradually felled
by the warriors's many weapons but by
this point Abel was approaching
exhaustion and there was still one more
enemy left standing it had been
unfurling destruction all on its own
angrily devouring the few Foundation
Personnel that were left and now the
scaly form ofp 682 came lumbering around
the corner the battle was brutal in this
universe AEL and the hard to destroy
reptile had never crossed paths before
but SCP 682 could smell the difference
in Abel's physiology his innate ability
to resist damage and resurrect time and
time again the creature already held the
stain for anything and everything living
and so presented with a man who
technically couldn't stop living SCP 682
entered an Unstoppable rage State taking
the exhausted able down with ease but
losing in a grudge match against SCP 682
wasn't quite as bad as things were about
to get for AEL Reviving inside of his
Stone sarcophagus the ancient warrior
was confused the foundation Wen letting
him out it had been a long time years
even since he had last died even
temporarily over the course of all of
his Omega 7 missions he hadn't needed to
reappear back inside SCP 0761 for quite
a considerable while and now that he had
a very large seed of Doubt had been sown
the 05 Council were Furious just as
angry at SCP 076-2 apparent failure as
able was the perfect operational track
record of their top anomalous asset was
now tarnished the question started to
spread through the council members if
their sword Wheeling virtually
invulnerable secret weapon wasn't as
effective as they had previously thought
then what was the use of continuing to
deploy AEL and so began a debate within
the 05 Council upon what was to be the
fate of SCP 076-2 in this universe he
had served the foundation well but a
weapon that is only effective even 90%
of the time still leaves a margin of
error it was that risk that potential
for error knowing that Abel wouldn't
always succeed in this missions that
caused the 05 Council to reconsider his
applications as a field operative there
were some in the council who argued that
this was a highly specific isolated
incident the chaos Insurgency had
specifically engineered the SCP 682
Escape as a way to draw Abel out after
all just because he failed this time did
not indicate a pattern of failure but
this argument was eventually shot down
especially when the foundation's Ethics
Committee decided to throw in their two
cents they demanded AEL status as a
field agent be revoked and levied for
the immediate disbanding for the Omega 7
project bulling replacements for that
task force from other mtfs at the
foundation had left them with a
significantly depleted reserve of troops
and then came the argument about just
how acceptable the losses were when AEL
was let loose a decision was ultimately
made to for at least the moment resend
SCP 076-2 field operative privileges and
suspend any further development of or
recruitment into Omega 7 however there
was one crucial factor that nobody on
the council had taken into consideration
when they made their verdict and that
was how badly Abel would react to the
news as you may have already predicted
Abel was Furious to hear he would be
held in containment until further notice
his anger stemmed not from his defeat at
the jaws of sccp 682 but at how quick
the foundation seemingly was to question
his combat prowess he lost one battle
out of hundreds thousands even and all
of a sudden the 05 Council were going to
lock him away all because of one defeat
you dare Abel bellowed when he was given
the news I Am The Greatest Warrior on
this planet and have been made a pwn by
your foundation I give you my strength
my skill and the moment I falter you
turn your back on me you dare you dare I
will show you what real power looks like
overcome with rage it didn't take long
for able to force his way out of
containment he'd been active as a field
agent within the foundation for so long
now that he had long since figured out a
way to escape his underwater prison
before the emergency containment
measures had a chance to stop him as he
broke free he made sure to take down
plenty of security staff along the way
and to make matters worse he didn't stop
there before long Abel was on a war path
against the SCP Foundation every few
days reports would come in of a massacre
at a foundation facility
security footage recovered from the
wreckage after each incident would show
Abel arriving primed for battle a sword
in each Hand by the time he left after
his brutal remorseless attack he'd be
drenched in the blood of the entire
site's Personnel the foundation had
little in its once huge Arsenal to fight
back with given the number of MTF agents
reassigned to Omega 7 their forces were
far more limited if not almost depleted
they dispatched attachments to clean up
the wake of ael's Destruction but not
one Squad sent after the anomalous
Warrior came back alive part of the
problem was the foundation couldn't
predict where AEL would show up next or
which of their sights he knew about and
was planning to hit from their
perspective his attacks were spontaneous
the result of Rage at the foundation but
without any premeditated plan in mind
and that was exactly what Abel wanted
them to think by seeming to attack at
random he was therefore able to cover
the true intention behind each each
engagement he was looking for something
during his considerable time leading
Omega 7 he had heard about a machine
that could improve anything placed
inside of it SCP 914 better known as the
Clockworks and before long Abel found
what he was looking for by the time the
foundation realized what the Unstoppable
Warrior's plan was it was already too
late AEL was storming into the facility
that housed SCP 914 with no intention of
leaving until he used it the foundation
had banned testing of biological matter
within the Clockworks but able wasn't
beholden to their rules anymore in fact
he barely was when he'd worked with them
before cutting down guards and
researchers survivors fleeing in Terror
able stepped up towards the massive
gears and cogs the Clockwork components
that made up SCP 914 he wasted no time
setting the machine to very fine with
this setting the Clockworks would take
whatever was in the input booth and
improve prove it usually by giving it
anomalous Properties or in the case of
Abel by giving him further anomalous
properties stepping inside the were of
Machinery drowned out the emergency
alarms as Abel reached his goal to
become the ultimate warrior the
embodiment of the very concept itself
racing to the scene a chopper cleared
the smoke as it approached under an
emergency executive order from the 05
Council the few surviving remnants of
the foundation's mobile task force
forces had been combined into a singular
Strike Team there were not many left
considering how many others from their
units had been previously siphoned into
Omega 7 only to die as collateral damage
in the team's missions with able
remember SCP 076-2 is a priority Target
the field commander barked while the MTF
Strike Team held their guns nervously
aboard the aircraft primary objective is
to neutralize him by any means reports
indicate that he may be trying to access
SCP 914 so be advised An Almighty
explosion boomed through the Airborne
vehicle engulfing the cockpit in Flames
mayday mayday mayday Chopper one has
been hit we're going down the commander
radioed to Foundation command everyone
braak yourselves for impact the
helicopter spiraled out of the air
crashing to the ground in a Twisted hunk
of metal the surviving members of the
Strike Team scrambled out of the
wreckage hauling the more badly wounded
out of the ruined aircraft contact
someone yelled in horror enemy contact
behind us the remaining Foundation foot
soldiers turned and Drew their weapons
opening fire on something suspended a
few feet in the air above them a hail of
gunfire rang out as the team opened fire
the second they saw who it was it was
Abel and he was flying floating above
them his hair whipped in the wind the
oncoming storm of bullets seemed to
Ricochet off his skin in actuality they
weren't even hitting him melting away
before they could make contact they
might as well have been firing
peashooters for how little effect effect
their guns had the barrage only stopped
when one of the Strike Team launched a
short-range rocket at the newly refined
Warrior it detonated but when the smoke
from the blast cleared AEL was still
hovering in the air without so much as a
scratch my turn he announced reaching
into his pocket Dimension AEL pulled
something out not a weapon not yet
instead it was a formless dark shadowy
mass that moved like liquid metal
reacting to the movement of his hand as
he drew the substance out it reformed
seemingly at Abel's command and it
wasn't just swords he could create now
drawing on his experiences from his
Omega 7 missions any weapon that Abel
had previously seen or could think of he
now had at his disposal the Strike Team
looked up in horror as a veritable swarm
of black non-reflective constructs
hovered in the air on either side of AEL
each one in the shape of a rocket
flinging both arms towards the
foundation troops able sent his New
Creations raining down on them the
Strike Team turned heel and fled for
their lives although none of them got
very far Able's Rockets engulfed the
area around them in a volley of
explosions leaving not a single thing
standing he had just effortlessly built
an air strike from virtually thin air
and thrown it at the foundation's last
remaining MTF agents and he wasn't done
there with his Newfound Powers ael's
Campaign Of Destruction swept the entire
world in a last Act of desperation the
SCP Foundation offered freedom to any
anomaly that permanently took down SCP
076-2 they all flooded out of
containment to take their shot the
plague doctor the shy guy the Spectre
but they barely slowed AEL down his new
constructs were devastating weapons
taking the form of not just blades but
projectiles of every size and shape all
of them lethal before long Abel had Lain
waste to the entire Foundation but still
he wanted more SCP 914 hadn't just
improved ael's existing anomalous powers
and granted him the ability to fly at
supersonic speeds in doing so it had
Amplified his range too he loathed the
human race and sought to absolutely
decimate every single living thing no
one could best him in combat now and in
his mind Twisted by anger not one of
them was worthy of his respect he tore
planes apart with his bare hands smashed
tanks to pieces and leveled entire
cities with his unlimited weapons it
took a few years maybe a decade at the
most but by the end of it Abel sat at
top a pile of billions upon billions of
bones with his refined abilities he had
done something Unthinkable committed
omnicide he had killed everyone in the
world of course this was indeed another
world one different to ours luckily here
our version of able is still locked up
underwater but somewhere out there there
is an Abel who is watching the sun
rising over an entirely dead World his
world want to own an SCP of your own go
to SCP swag.com for premium anomalous
merchandise man it's even better on the
15th read oh hello I didn't see you
there dear viewers of SCP explained I'm
on break between supervising SCP 682
termination attempts and inspecting the
mops we use on SCP 173s leavings so I
decided to do what all the cool people
are doing in their spare time right now
rereading chainsaw man
the hit manga by Japanese author and
artist tatsuki Fujimoto for the
uninitiated it's the story of denji a
poor young man from Japan who makes his
living hunting Devils dangerous
creatures that are embodiments of
Mankind's greatest fears but when that
living leads to him dying at the hands
of a gang of zombie Yakuza believe me it
makes sense in context he bonds with the
legendary chainsaw devil and is reborn
as chainsaw man an unconventional super
superhero who chainsaws first and asks
questions later naturally I was eager to
see how one of our own bloodthirsty
Killers would Faire against dji's
chainsaws of Fury so I selected the most
violent battle hardened and Carnage
hungry anomaly out there SCP 076-2 The
Immortal Warrior known as Abel the two
of them have a surprising amount of
things in common both are effectively
Immortal and can revive after sustaining
massive physical injuries both
absolutely love to fight with their
array of deadly weapons and anomalous
strength both have been part of
experimental operations groups with
denji being a member of Japan's Public
Safety devil Hunters division 4 and Abel
being an ex-member of the SCP
foundation's disastrous Pandora box
mobile task force most of which he later
massacred out of boredom you can
probably see why these two really did
feel like the perfect matchup so after
forcing the trusty
read every currently available volume of
Chainsaw man and compute years of ael's
gruesome battle data I've set up the
perfect simulation for your viewing
pleasure and hey fellow fans of the
manga isn't it horrifying that even we
beat mappa to the punch of animating
this
[Music]
thing oh God that joke will age poorly
if that anime comes up before this
anyway let's crank this machine into
action and let her rep Japan
1997 everything is roasting in the July
heat Men In Black Harrison Ford's Air
Force 1 and airbud are hitting theaters
for the first time everything is right
with the world that's why over in the
headquarters of the public safety devil
hunting Department denji our chainsaw
loving hero is being praised by his kind
boss and Mentor figure Mima a lovable
supportive woman who will never do
anything wrong she even loves dogs how
could a person who loves dogs ever be
evil that very morning denji and his
chainsaw man form managed to defeat the
accidentally making a mistake on your
tax forms and now you're going to prison
devil who had been terrorizing downtown
Tokyo it was a challenging battle but in
the end he'd managed to turn the tables
and defeat the creature by setting it on
fire needless to say Mima was extremely
pleased with dji's work here but now she
had considerably more Graver news to
impart she'd gotten word from an Envoy
of another organization that hunts down
dangerous and anomalous creatures the
SCP Foundation that an extremely lethal
entity had breached their containment
and was now somewhere in Japan the
entity in question was not a devil and
thereby would be working on a different
rule set Mima opened a file fact to her
by the foundation yes remember this is
set in 1997 and gave denji The crucial
Lowdown several hours ago the entity
known as Abel had resurrected from his
huge black sarc cagus in the underwater
chamber of the classified facility
containment area 25b after waking up
Abel had slaughtered his way through the
entire base killing every SCP Foundation
operative in his path and then swimming
out into the Pacific Ocean sometime
after that he infiltrated a Japanese
cargo ship and murdered all the workers
on board before steering the ship back
towards the Land of the Rising Sun where
he hoped to claim even more victims Mima
told denji that it would fall to him and
his associates to stop this AEL With a
Little Help from the SCP foundation's
intelligence but be warned Abel is an
incredible combatant with extreme
physical strength and durability as well
as surprising tactical intelligence it
wouldn't be an easy fight but Mima
promised that if denji won she'd hug him
and go to a nearby karaoke bar with him
denji replied consider him dead already
miss Mima meanwhile able was walking
through the slums of Tokyo marveling at
the neon signs for bars and clubs his
journey to Japan hadn't been an accident
Abel had been to Japan once before in
the year
16005 he'd faced the legendary Japanese
philosopher and swordsman Miato Musashi
considered by many to be one of the
greatest warriors in human history Abel
had dueled Masashi who famously wielded
two katanas at once in the hills of the
harima province where after a tense
battle mhi cut him down Abel would not
resurrect again during mhi's lifetime
but the battle gave him a deep and
abiding respect for the legendary
Warrior Abel knew that if the
opportunity ever rose again he would
return to Japan in hopes of experiencing
such a brilliant battle yet again but
the industrial and technological boom
had changed so much it was no longer the
quiet and pastoral Japan he'd
experienced but a booming epicenter of
trade and commerce he founded all
strange and perplexing suddenly he found
himself surrounded by a group of
Japanese street thugs many of them
wielding switch blades they laughed at
his strange outfit which to them looked
like an old worn bed sheet one of the
smarter members of the group had already
decided to go home when the others made
up their mind to mug Abel the Warriors
extensive tattoos made him look like a
middle eastern Yakuza Dawn the rest
however were happy to take their chances
with him empty your pockets if that
goofy toga even has pockets the leader
said holding up his switchblade unless
you want to get cut Abel just smirked
and Drew a pair of long obsidian daggers
in the following Moment The Alley was
filled with screams then was silent yet
again Abel walked on breathing a sigh of
disappointment at how incredibly
mediocre this first fight had been his
blades dripping with fresh blood moushi
is rolling in his grave Abel thought to
himself meanwhile across town denji and
the rest of division 4 were mobilizing
it was him the serious sword Wheeling
Aki and the adorable pathologically
lying blood fiend power they'd been told
over the phone by a man named Dr brgh
that Abel would be relatively easy to
track down he's not known for his
subtlety all you need to do is follow
the trail of Carnage he causes wherever
he goes from the way he talks about him
it seems almost as though Dr brigh Bears
a personal grudge against able how
strange power didn't seem intimidated
she proudly proclaimed I don't think
this battle will be difficult at all in
fact I faced this able before and
defeated him handily Aki sighed and
asked when did this happen last Tuesday
of course she replied power had only
heard about Abel this morning but denji
and Aki had learned better than to
dispute her at this point suddenly a
large television screen that had been
previously relaying an ad for a
cuttingedge stereo system cut to an
emergency news report there had been a
horrific incident in downtown Tokyo
where a bar had been attacked and most
of its patrons murdered by a deranged
tattooed man carrying a pair of huge
swords Aki immediately recognized this
place the bar was Yakuza owned if this
able was on the hunt for worthy
opponents it makes all the sense in the
world that Japan's iconic crime
syndicates would be his first Target
denji Aki and power knew exactly where
they needed to go over at the bar Abel
was having a whale of a Time innocent
patrons were running and screaming while
the yakaza engaged in an allout war with
a terrifying inhuman Warrior several of
them had already been cut down two
Yakuza soldiers behind the bar were
reloading illegal ues and preparing to
return fire both were sweating terrified
by the sudden random attack when they'd
shot him before he' managed to dodge
most of the bullets and expertly block
the rest with his swords who the hell
had sent this monster was he with the
Triads the Russian mob or some devil
summoned by the Japanese government to
crack down on them whatever the case he
seemed almost impossible to kill the two
men stood back up and opened fire able
held his two swords and spun like a
propeller blocking all the bullets
almost effortlessly he then produced
another dagger seemingly from thin air
and threw it directly into the heart of
one of the two remaining Yakuza behind
the bar he dropped to the ground dead
instantly leaving only his friend alive
in a bar full of corpses that's when
Abel noticed a decorative Catana behind
the bar he smiled and ordered the
surviving Yakuza Soldier to pick up the
sword and give him a real fight the
hapless monster realized in that moment
that this guy was truly crazy whoever he
was but what choice did he have now with
teror in his heart the last surviving
Yakuza grabbed the katana and un
sheathed it good able said his voice
deep and menacing now come fight me
let's see if you last a few seconds
longer than your worthless friends shall
we he did not the second the yakaza ran
towards Abel and the ancient swordsman
swiped at him with one of his blades
cutting through the katana and the
opponent holding it a puny gangster
never stood a chance against a deadly
Immortal Warrior and Abel was Furious
the last time he was here he faced a
truly expert killer who even managed to
end Abel's life in a single combat and
now he was slaying insects in a karaoke
bar pathetic suddenly his ears picked up
he turned to see a red axe flying at his
head at incredible speeds with his
superhuman reflexes he managed to dodge
just in time but the axe still cleaved
off a chunk of his hair as it passed
Abel could see the one who threw it
standing at the entrance to the bar it
was the blood fiend power who made the
axe out of her own blood standing next
to her were denji and Aki denji wielding
an Axe and Aki stoically observing damn
Miss Mima promis we do karaoke at this
bar if I beat you Deni said you're going
down for this Abel smiled and pulled out
another pair of blades finally he roared
Warriors who fight the oldfashioned way
I feared the years had stolen you all
from me power step forward producing
another Blood axe from nowhere she
yelled tremble in fear Abel
is I your arch nemesis the mighty power
Abel had literally never seen her before
in his thousands of years of life but he
appreciated that these warriors were at
least able to match his level of drama
as far as he was concerned the fight was
on but even Abel didn't know the level
of fighting he was getting in for here
as he charged forward the trio split
immediately surrounding him good tactics
Abel thought to himself already this was
promising AI who had remained quiet up
to this point attacked first he drew a
tatano knife from his suit jacket and
slashed at Abel with impressive speed
but unlike three of the other combatants
in this situation Aki was only human
which gave him a serious disadvantage
abble decided it would be best to put
him out of commission first with a quick
and brutal kick to the chest Aki was
thrown against the wall with the
majority of his ribs broken revved up by
his own bloodlust able turned to denji
in power and grin like a maniac this was
already the most fun he'd had had in a
long time who are these people doesn't
matter he thought they'll be dead soon
anyway well AEL was still locked in
thought power pulled out a comically
large Hammer made out of her own blood
and brought it down towards Abel he was
surprised by the sudden attack did this
girl have the same weapon producing
Powers as him this just keeps getting
more interesting is the end AEL power
screamed as the hammer came down you
have once again been defeated by the
Mighty power again just to clarify these
two had never met each other but it was
already too late Abel punched upwards
his clenched fist colliding with the
hammer he h it with such terrifying
force that power's blood Hammer
shattered against his knuckles and that
same instant Abel noticed denji running
at him with an axe from behind Abel
produced another obsidian dagger and
threw it into dji's forehead dropping
him to the ground immediately pathetic
power tried to produce another weapon
but she used up too much blood already
before she had a chance to make anything
substantial Abel sprung forwards with
terrifying speed trying to land a
killing blow but even weakened power was
freakishly fast she was able to dodge
his blow and kick him in the ribs
momentarily stunning him of course she
took the time to gloat putting her hands
on her hips and laughing victoriously
need a second to catch your breath Abel
it is to be
expected none can keep up with me she
grously announced
perhaps you should just give up and
agree to become my servant I might even
teach you a thing or two about fighting
suddenly Abel was standing right in
front of her squeezing her throat with
his iron grip he smiled flashing teeth
and said if you want to kill kill don't
talk with a surprisingly minimal amount
of strength he squeezed and H a crunch
from power's neck he dropped her limp
body to the ground lucky for power Abel
wasn't aw that a fiend like power can
survive an injury like this as long as
she's fed some more blood instead he
just sighed in disappointment is that
all you weaklings have to offer he
bellowed Aki barely conscious after
being kicked against the wall remained
just conscious enough to activate his
contract with a Powerful Beast known as
the fox devil he twists his hands into a
strange gesture and Whispers the word
con before falling unconscious but
that's still enough suddenly a gigantic
demonic Fox claw burst through the wall
of the bar spraying dust and Rubble
everywhere Abel was definitely not
expecting that he dodged several times
as the claw swiped for him often barely
missing him for its last Strike It
lunged Forward and Rak four claw marks
across his chest Abel was shocked by the
sudden pain it felt fantastic he pulled
a long obsidian spear out of one of his
pocket dimensions and forced it down
through the fox Devil's paw and into the
ground pinning it in place after a
moment of thrashing the claw dissipated
into smoke lending Abel another Victory
though even he would admit this was a
more exciting fight than the other ones
had been was that it had he gained total
Victory once more just like he so often
did these days he was about to take pity
on himself when denji rose up behind him
how about a rematch denji asked abble
grinned he liked this kid challenge me
child Abel said well since you you asked
denji smirked denji reached into his
shirt and grabbed the rip cord emerging
from his chest it was time to go into
overdrive on this thing he gave it a
mighty yank and like the Rev of a
chainsaw the madness began denji
transformed giant blades emerging from
his arms and his head transformed into a
toothy saw blade nightmare he gave a
mechanical Roar that spewed smoke this
wasn't just denji anymore this was
chainsaw man now this Abel thought
feeling his adrenaline spike is more
like it following dji's lead Abel
reached into one of his pocket
dimensions and pulled out one of his
favorite weapons one he' only previously
used against the mighty hard to destroy
reptile SCP 682 the chainsaw Claymore a
huge two-handed sword with the eternally
twisting shredding teeth of a chainsaw
ever circulating around it it was time
for Chainsaw versus chainsaw what the
hell are you waiting for chain saw man
roared are we going to stand around all
day or are we going to fight Abel
couldn't have said it better himself the
two charged at one another at lightning
speeds chainsaw clashing against chain
sword the sheer force of the contact was
enough to send a shock wave blasting
through the bar that rapidly became a
power struggle each of them trying hard
to force their chainsaws out of the
stalemate realizing that this time he
perhaps couldn't win with raw strength
Abel back flipped away to reassess his
options but chainsaw man had no
intention of giving Abel time to think
about it he darted towards Abel with the
weight and momentum of a runaway freight
train if Abel hadn't raised his Claymore
to Parry it would have been shredded to
Pieces by the devil's saws in an instant
instead the two of them rocketed out of
the nearby wall in a Cascade of debris
causing everyone on the outside Street
to run for their lives the two quickly
stood from the stumble the two quickly
stood up catching their breath
impressive Abel said you're much better
than the others in instead of replying
denji briefly retracted his arm
chainsaws and grabbed a nearby parked
car throwing it directly at Abel Abel
reacted quickly cleaving the car in half
with his Claymore and charging for
chainsaw man again just before AEL could
land a lethal strike chainsaw man
deployed his chainsaws again blocking
the blow abble sped around him trying to
strike again and again but chainsaw man
blocked every strike with stunning
efficacy Abel was astonished few had
ever been able to go toe to- Toe with
him like this before
he could feel his heart pounding
gloriously in his chest he would give
denji A Warrior's death with a furious
yell Abel brought down the chainsaw
Claymore for a devastating vertical
strike but chainsaw man was ready he
arranged his armed chainsaws in a cross
formation like a giant pair of scissors
and caught Abel's chain swword between
them chainsaw man pulled his arms in
opposite directions slicing Abel's
mighty sword in half the immortal
swordsman skidded backwards to avoid the
Fallout producing two smaller blades
immediately this chainsaw man just kept
exceeding expectations didn't he Abel
would need to change tactics if he
wanted to win this one chainsaw man was
impressed by the speed and tenacity of
his Foe for someone who apparently
wasn't even a devil able sure packed a
hell of a punch did he ever run out of
those damned weapons as though
attempting to answer chainsaw man's
question for him Abel began running
around his flank rapidly producing and
throwing blades and axes in a startling
volley chainsaw man was able to to use
his chainsaw arms and face to block most
of them but not all of them several
daggers and small throwing axes
splattered into the tender flesh of
Chainsaw Man's Chest Abel had
successfully wounded him and he wasn't
done feeling a little more confident now
AEL decided to take a different tactic
he produced a large spiked mace from
thin air and ran at chainsaw man while
the devil was still recovering from his
projectile attack with one brutal whack
he sent denji flying down the street car
a rut into the concrete beneath him but
Abel wasn't done while chainsaw man was
still trying to recover Abel leaped on
to him and began beating him into the
ground with his mace the strikes were so
brutal they shook the Earth and sent
cracks across the surrounding ground
then Abel stopped he realized for a
moment that he was letting his blood
lust get the better of him this was
dishonorable where would be the fun in
beating this boy to death while he lay
on the ground and depriving himself of
one of the greatest opponent he's had in
quite some time no that would not do at
all he'd give him one more chance on
your feet boy Abel said you fight well
get up and carry on I won't let a beast
as rare as you die like a common dog
rise and fight me and Chainsaw man did
as he was told AEL was shocked to see
the very ground shatter underneath him
as chainsaw man burst up through it all
his swords at the ready the mace was
thrown from Abel's hands as chainsaw man
launched up towards him all metal teeth
and fury luckily for Abel he pulled out
a battle axe just in time to block the
flurry of brutal strikes from the patron
saint of chainsaws now this was a fight
even Musashi would be proud of yes Boy
Yes able yelled this is true combat
chainsaw man replied with the swing of
his blades which Abel was nearly able to
dodge the two finally landed back down
on the ground and able was fast enough
to bury his battle axe in chainsaw man's
shoulder before the devil could return a
blow to Abel the anomalous swordsman
pulled out a pair of his favorite swords
and locked chainsaw man's arms in place
chainsaw man was undeniably incredibly
powerful but it looked like Abel's
Superior experience and tactics might
save him this time what the hell are you
chainsaw man roared you've been a worthy
opponent boy those are few and far
between Abel said I'll remember you for
this but before Abel could execute a
killing blow he felt the blood red
throwing axe stick into his back Abel
winced in pain to see Power and Aki
about 30 ft behind him power was
propping Aki up he donated some of his
blood to bring her back to life and she
was just as delusionally cocky as ever
abble was about to say something but he
already made a fatal mistake letting his
guard down before another word could
pass the cursed Warrior's lips one of
Chainsaw man's armed chainsaws passed
directly through his heart tearing it
apart with an Able's chest it was a
sudden and decisive killing blow
chainsaw man pulled his saw back out of
Abel's chest stained with the deadly
anomalies blood Abel collapsed to the
ground wheezing and bleeding profusely
from the hole in his chest but strangely
as power Ai and Chainsaw man converged
around him they realized he was smiling
thank you Abel said and died yet again
with the battle W like an Incredible
Hulk made of metal chainsaw man
transformed back into denji the Trio
stood around Abel's corpse deeply
confused as to what had just happened if
this was the kind of thing the SCP
Foundation normally dealt with they all
silently agree that perhaps it would be
better not to get involved with them in
the future except power of course who
said you two should be thanking me for
defeating him you both owe me drinks for
this hundreds of miles away in a black
sarcophagus deep underwater surrounded
by professional SCP Foundation divers
Abel's body once again returned who
knows how long he'd remained sleeping in
there but what we do know is that his
deathless sleep was suffused with the
sweet dreams knowing that this world
still held worthy opponents and for able
that was everything in the mid 1800s a
group of archaeologists from England
embarked on an expedition to Mongolia
the expedition was headed by Jonathan
Davis his long-term research partner
Jason Porter and their assistant Marvin
Thomas with them they brought a ship all
the necessary equipment and a team of 10
workers to Aid with the Dig and the
transportation of any relics back to the
British is there they found a number of
historically significant artifacts one
of which was described in Davis's
Journal as a most marvelous Discovery
the likes of which the world has never
known it will surely be regarded as the
crown jewel of our findings and I
delight at the thought of what ancient
Secrets it may allow us to uncover
unfortunately for him he would never get
to find out when the ship arrived back
on the shores of England those waiting
for its return discovered that every
single man on board was dead their
mangled bodies littered the deck of the
ship and Jonathan Davis's head had been
torn clean off whatever had killed them
it was far stronger than all 13 men
combined given the unusual circumstances
of these deaths the artifacts were
seized by the oddies occult and
Paranormal Society or oops one of the
many groups started by stuffy English
gentlemen of that era that mainly
functioned as a glorified Cabinet of
Curiosities and placed in their inner
sanctum the largest and most impressive
of these was a large black stone Cube
covered with strange symbols which they
displayed prominently for several years
until one day the same dark force that
killed those archaeologists on their own
ship stirred once more something escaped
from within the stone killing everyone
present in the inner sanctum and leaving
a trail of more bodies in its wake until
eventually it was apprehended by the SCP
Foundation placed in containment and
designated SCP
076 SCP 076 consists of two separate
components a stone Cube SCP
0761 and the humanoid contained inside
of the cube or SCP 076-2 SCP 0761 is a
3M cube of black metamorphic Stone
covered in patterned Engravings that
have not been matched to any known
civilization analysis via radio isotope
suggests that the cube is at least
10,000 years old though an exact date of
origin could not be determined there is
a door on one side sealed with a lock
surrounded by 20 smaller locks all
arranged in a circular pattern the
foundation has not been able to locate
any of the keys and therefore is unable
to lock the door this is unfortunate
given the nature of the figure that
lurks inside the cube chained inside of
a stone coffin this is the resting place
of SCP 076-2 also known as Abel Abel is
a humanoid male who appears to be in his
late 20s with black hair gray eyes and
olive skin in spite of his youthful
appearance his age is estimated to be
around the same as the cube that holds
him his body is covered in tattoos
depicting various occult icons and
images of demonic fa es not uncommon for
warrior casts of old when he is encased
in his coffin within his Stone prison
Abel is technically dead and registers
no vital signs of any kind however he
does not stay dead on an occasional
basis with no apparent cause he will
wake up and reanimate once he is awake
and aware he will attempt to leave the
cube by any means necessary if he
manages to escape he will look for the
nearest human being and attempt to kill
them once he has latched on to a Target
he will enter a rage state that will not
stop until he is killed though as his
anomalous nature implies this death is
never permanent and he will always
awaken again eventually terminating Abel
in order to stop one of his Rampages is
often difficult as he possesses strength
and durability far beyond the
capabilities of an ordinary man he has
superhuman power and speed and though
his physical body can be damaged he does
not appear to respond to pain and
continues to fight through extreme
injuries that would take most targets
down during his time in Foundation
custody he has displayed the following
abilities over the course of 4 minutes
while trying to attack a research
assistant that happened to cross into
his line of sight moments before he
ripped through a reinforced Steel
security door with his bare hands
breaking the steel apart as if it were
layers of tinf foil during another
incident he was able to run a distance
of 64 M and under 3 seconds to catch up
to an armored van filled with Foundation
guard
while security staff attempted to
neutralize him during the same incident
he took several 50 caliber rounds to the
head and continued to move and kill for
several minutes after in spite of having
literal holes in his head and missing
portions of vital brain matter during
another Escape he got a hold of a piece
of Steel rebar which he used to swat
bullets from handguns and assault rifles
out of the air like he was batting a
ball with a tennis racket during another
attempted Escape after killing half a
dozen DCL classes along the way
Foundation staff were eventually able to
trap the entity in a vat of water
sealing the top where he tread water
furiously for an hour before eventually
suffocating this suggests that unlike
most people who will asphyxiate after
only a few minutes without oxygen he can
survive for at least an hour the most
notable of his anomalous skills however
is his ability to produce weapons
usually bladed from thin air whenever he
wants to slowed down security footage
has shown that he does this by pulling
the weapons out of a tiny Rift in space
a portal to another dimension of some
kind it is unsure where this portal
leads to or how AEL accesses it but it
appears to function as his own personal
Armory stocked with an endless supply of
black non-reflected bladed weapons which
vanish as soon as they leave his grasp
though it is difficult and often
dangerous to do so Abel can in fact be
killed some previously affected methods
of termination have included fire from
multiple heavy caliber machine guns
suffocation
being crushed between a 13.6 metric ton
piece of elevator equipment cremation
via grenade placed inside of a cavity in
his chest and the detonation of an
on-site nuclear warhead every time SCP
076-2 is killed his corpse quickly
decays at an unnaturally rapid rate
until he has turned into a pile of dust
then the door to the cube as well as the
coffin inside will slam shut and the
lock on the outside will rotate shut
somehow Abel's body will then reform
inside the coffin this process can take
anywhere from 6 hours to over 20 years
after a series of failed experiments
containment procedures for SCP 076 were
amended to the current procedures in
place SCP 076 is placed in containment
area 25b located 200 M below sea level
tunneled into solid bedrock in an area
with limited seismic activity the only
way to access this area is via An
Elevator Shaft which is broken up every
50 m with a reinforced blast door made
of Shield shielding that is 20 cm thick
when the Elevator Shaft is not being
used it is flooded with seawater the
containment area includes an outer
security perimeter outfitted with
security Personnel trained in counter
intrusion and Close Quarters combat an
administrative and support area where
on-site Personnel can live in rest a
primary containment Zone filled with
seawater and made of a 7 m Cube encased
in reinforced material and then a
killing Corridor that is 150 m in size
with an electrical system able to
deliver a 20,000 volt shock in the event
of an attempted containment breach the
security station at the entrance of the
killing Corridor must be staffed with at
least three armed security guards at all
times in the event of a Containment
Breach all staff on site must go to the
closest security station immediately for
weapons and armor the staff will remain
at alert condition one until AEL has
been neutralized and recontained if 90
minutes pass after a full breach without
the order to stand down being given the
entire facility will be flooded with
seawater and the access shaft will be
sealed for 24 hours this is considered
an extreme measure as it will kill any
site staff present but desperate times
call for desperate measures after the
containment procedures were amended and
file updated do reducted submitted a
complaint to director Maria Jones head
of recordkeeping and information
security administration the
correspondence reads as follows I have
to go on record as saying that I
seriously object to the proposed visions
of the SCP 076 special containment
procedures file I know that redact all
important stuff already claims it as a
security risk but you and I both know
it's just top brass trying to sweep
their biggest and most embarrassing
mistake ever under the rug Omega 7
happened it existed those people died
because you screwed up and you can't
change that no matter how hard you tried
to hide it for God's sake man those
people guarding him deserve to know
exactly what he is and what he did what
we we did how we screwed up so they'll
know better so what was Omega 7 what
could have possibly constituted one of
the foundation's worst greatest most
humiliating mistakes ever following the
death of an agent whose identity has
been redacted who had managed to best
Abel several times in combat the
foundation became aware of an intriguing
possibility whenever Abel encountered
the rare individual he perceived as
Superior or at least equal to him in
combat his uncontrollable rage would
subside and he would develop a kind of
respect when abble learned of the man's
death he calmed down and was coherent
enough to interview he was distressed at
the death which had occurred as
collateral damage in an air strike
intended to contain another SCP he
explained his feelings on the subject a
man like that deserves to die in combat
so close to his opponent he can feel his
breath not in some destruction ordered
by cowardly Kings and princes safe in
their palaces the rest of you you
disgust me I don't even have the urge to
strike you down after this interview the
researcher who conducted it recommended
that the foundation attempt to find a
way to work with Abel and somehow
militarize him in accordance with the
bow commission's desire to use SC SCP
objects for tactical purposes a mobile
task force was proposed referred to as
Omega 7 or by its nickname Pandora's Box
task force Omega 7 was to consist of
between 10 and 20 field agents split up
into teams of three and five people each
members of these teams have selected a
roster of Highly qualified field agents
and chosen by Abel himself their purpose
would be to provide support to him
during high-risk fieldwork and combat
based situations Abel was outfitted with
a device attached to his neck that if it
was triggered or interfered with in any
way would detonate and Destroy his
spinal cord trachea and the major blood
vessels of his neck killing him
instantly a tracking device was was also
attached to Abel in order to keep the
foundation informed of his whereabouts
at all times Abel was instructed to
refrain from any unnecessary killing or
violence and only attack when ordered to
this operation was off to a bit of a
rocky start and the head researcher in
charge of it added this addendum to the
initial project proposal for God's sake
find these guys something to do ael's
getting bored and he's starting putting
his team through live fire exercises
they get bullets he gets training
weapons have you ever seen seen someone
break a man's jaw using a Nerf sword
he's not going to stop until someone
gets killed indeed Abel was getting
restless and the foundation needed to
find a way to keep him busy until he
could be occupied with bloodier Pursuits
this project report was submitted
regarding ael's activities in light of
SCP 076-2 proficient use of the Sumerian
language researchers have asked it to
translate several documents while it
originally replied with disinterest it
has translated some of the documents it
found worthy of its attention most of
the documents chosen by a CP 076-2 were
regarding battles or Legendary Heroes
one of its favorites in particular being
the Epic of Gilgamesh however one
researcher presented it with the symbol
from SCP 073 upon sight of this SCP
076-2 became highly enraged killing
several of the researchers before its
kill switch could be activated when
revived in question about this SCP 076-2
responded aggressively and that line of
questioning was immediate dropped it is
recommended anything pertaining to SCP
073 never be brought to the attention of
SCP 076-2 and that the two are never to
be in the same facility eventually the
chance to see Omega 7 in action came
about enable and his task force were
deployed at the request of the bo
commission though details have been
redacted from the official file the
mission was deemed a success and general
Bo thanked the research team in an email
with the subject line a job well done he
wrote excellent work doctor the mission
went exactly as expected we'll be
calling you again if we need your help
this new chapter of the project bred
Discord between the two lead researchers
assigned to AEL from here on referred to
as Dr W and Dr P Dr P was highly in
favor of Omega 7 and its military
applications while Dr W strongly
disproved believing the project to be an
example of the military forcing the SCP
Foundation to do its dirty work he
responded to the General's
congratulations with a strongly worded
email to his colle League too strongly
worded to repeat here to summarize it
neatly he was very upset following this
email and at Dr P's request Dr W was
reassigned to SCP 682 leaving him as the
sole researcher in charge of the Omega 7
project after a series of incidents
regarding Friendly Fire and casualties
within the task force itself most of
which occurred during ordinary combat
training Dr P sent an email to the
general despite our best efforts subject
AEL is proving difficult to control all
our attempts to keep him engaged have
been more or less unsuccessful the
problem is he's a perfect killing
machine and that's all he wants to do
which seems like exactly what we wanted
but the problem is we can't seem to turn
him off I'm running out of missions to
give him and the ones I've got left
aren't engaging him mentally he started
to lash out at the other team members
it's only a matter of time before
something goes wrong requesting
permission to discontinue the project
and neutralize AEL temporarily until we
can find something more for him to do
the General refused to agree to this
unacceptable neutralizing subject able
at this point is going to cause us an
unacceptable delay we'll have another
mission for you within a couple of weeks
all you have to do is keep him busy
until then send him on vacation or
something Dr P was stunned by this
response and Unsure how to proceed Not
only was there nowhere safe to Send Abel
on vacation short of firing him into the
furthest recesses of outer space where
he could not hurt anyone he was simply
not a man interested in Leisure rest or
vacation as a concept they had let the
tiger out of its cage and now all it
wanted to do was shred bite and kill he
tried to keep AEL occupied burning
through d-class on a daily basis that he
could use as human practice dummies but
eventually Able's craving for a
challenge became too strong an automated
alert went out to the staff on the site
where Abel was contained signaling the
start of a state of emergency SCP 076-2
has disabled the explosive color fail
safe and gone out of control all staff
to high alert further requests as events
warrant there is no surviving security
footage from this incident and there are
no witnesses to recount what happened
next here is what we know for sure
sometime after Abel escaped from his
explosive collar containment Area 25
began a 10-minute countdown for its
on-site nuclear warhead no staff were
able to successfully evacuate before the
Warhead detonated reducing the site to
Rubble site 67 and 68 active F ated FEMA
protocol and secured the location
meanwhile the stone coffin sealed itself
again the lock click shut and AEL began
to rebuild from almost nothing ashes to
ashes as they say and dust to dust
following this a revised psychological
profile of the entity was submitted SCP
076-2 either possesses a mind
constructed much differently than our
own or is completely insane with little
empathy or ideas in the way that we
would understand it Concepts such as sex
love and equality are completely foreign
ideas to SCP 076-2 or at least in
comparison to its way of viewing them
subject has shown that it is completely
disinterested in sex barely
differentiating between genders except
as a form of visual identification also
while subject seems to greatly enjoy the
Act of Killing causing pain either
emotionally or physically holds no
attraction to it intelligence tests have
been widely inconclusive when applied to
SCP 076 2 and no accurate result has yet
been obtained this is due to the fact
that no communication is possible with
the subject when in its rage State
subject displays knowledge of several
languages including English but most
notable is its knowledge of several
dialects of ancient Sumerian which seems
to be its preferred language SCP 076 has
nothing but contempt for human beings
and will kill them on sight no
communication is to be attempted with
the subject Abel wandered through the
Sands a lone Warrior dragging a Long
Dark Sword behind him his black cloak
flowing in the gentle breeze the sword
was thirsty it had been too long since
it tasted blood what had it been a day
since he cut down 10 men in a Tavern
without breaking a sweat they' bled and
scream like pigs as he diced them into
bloody chunks he couldn't remember their
faces they hadn't earned that very few
combatants had been remarkable enough to
Warrant committing to me memory it was
all just more dead flesh he took a sip
from his canteen inside did this world
hold no more challenges what a boring
eternity was laying out before him his
burden as The Greatest Warrior of all
time weighed on him heavier than the
chain it was old and Rusty levered over
his shoulder and grasped in one bloody
hand about 15 ft behind him the chain
was connected to a dark stone
sarcophagus that was as much a part of
him as his eyes skin or heart if ever he
was slain in the Glorious heat of battle
he'd rise out of it ready to fight and
kill another day all because of the
actions of his worthless good Forno
brother he looked up when he heard the
rush of footsteps and the clanking of
armor Warriors or whatever passed for
them around here about 20 of them
circled all around him yes oh yes his
grip tightened around his sword one of
the Warriors called out something about
him being under arrest by order of the
king for murders Beyond counting Abel
couldn't help but yawn words words words
why even bother he dropped the chain and
in one fluid motion he threw his sword
in a fraction of a second it pierced the
armor of the chattering man spearing him
through his formerly Beating Heart the
scream died in his throat he fell to his
knees then collapsed entirely the other
soldiers sent to kill or apprehend him
turned to their Fallen leader in gasp it
was that little gasp that moment of
distraction that sealed their Fates
ael's face cracked into a whisper of a
grin as he drew two long daggers from
the darkness of his coat he'd at least
try to have fun with this before the
others could even get over their
Leader's sudden death Abel had vaulted
forward and begun his delicate dance of
Slaughter every swing found its way
through armor and into skin he sliced
throats cleaved off heads parried blows
and pierced Hearts there was barely a
single scream Abel killed too quick for
screams in what would seem like the
blink of an eye for some the soldiers
around Abel fell most dead the rest
dying some looked up to him and their
dying moments in terrified awe of the
efficacy of their killer in their dying
moments they knew that they never had a
chance they might as well have been
facing the glistening Scythe of death
himself on the battlefield a on the
other hand rolled his eyes and sighed
another pathetic waste of time he sensed
movement in the corner of his eye one of
the wounded soldiers was limping to his
feet trying to use the sword to lever
himself off of the ground with a flick
of each wrist Abel tossed his knives
into the man killing him instantly it
really was that easy your attempt to
kill me does not offend me he said to
whoever was still able to hear what
offends me is that they would send so
few and and that those few would be such
pitiful excuses for soldiers this wasn't
a battle it was a mercy killing he was
ready to turn around grab the chain and
carry on walking when he felt a sudden
pain in his back there was a slight
whistle then another sharp Spike of pain
there were now two arrows sticking out
of his back Abel turned surprised and
saw a much larger Force standing behind
him Swordsmen archers men with clubs and
axes and chains the ones he'd killed
were little more than a distraction this
was the real threat this was a real army
perhaps these fools would give him some
actual exercise he reached into his
cloak and pulled out a mighty obsidian
battle axe at the very least he tried to
have a little fun turning this fighting
force into cold cuts a fog of arrows
sailed through the air as he charged
forwards Perforating his body but the
injuries didn't slow him down he lunged
slashed and cleaved even as the weapon
struck him he carried on killing person
after person at times it was almost
exciting almost but not quite by the
time he was done none were left standing
30 arrows were sticking out of him he'd
been cut deep by more weapons than he
could count on his fingers and toes he
was breathing deeply scarred chest
pumping up and down he coughed blood and
cracked his neck back into place they
might have cut him a little too deep
this time no matter Abel fell to his
knees feeling the life draining from him
he wondered when he awoke from the
coffin again what the world would look
like sometimes it was days sometimes
weeks months or even years as he fell
forward dying once again he'd hoped that
he'd wake into a world with a warrior or
beast that could actually challenge him
maybe someday this was one of Abel's
many lives hundreds of years before he
was contained by the SCP found
Foundation he's perhaps The Greatest
Warrior who ever lived died and lived
again he's a man so individually deadly
that not only is he kept in a
containment chamber Under the Sea
surrounded by highly trained and armored
guards he has his own localized on-site
nuclear weapon ready to blow away and
annihilate him and his entire
containment area if deemed necessary he
may not be a contagious anomalous
pathogen or a lethal mimic Hazard or a
giant Beast shooting World destroying
Fireballs in every Direction but if this
onean massacre was left to his own
devices there's no doubt that he would
methodically Slaughter his way through
the human race until an XK class endof
thee World scenario was practically
inevitable he was fueled by pure hatred
and an almost bottomless blood lust he
simply lived to fight and kill and not
only did he have the will and the skill
to be a pure force of annihilation but
his anomalous abilities also make him
perfectly tailored to the task he has
massively enhanced physical strength
speed and durability taking the kind of
damage that would kill several normal
humans to reliably put him down though
even that is only a temporary measure
Abel will always resurrect back into his
black sarcophagus to Menace the SCP
Foundation another day it is also
effectively impossible to disarm Abel
because he has the anomalous ability to
pull deadly edged weapons from localized
pocket Dimensions at will and his
proficiency with these weapons is unlike
any Warrior the world has ever known
before or since during containment
breaches he's regularly killed scores of
train Foundation guards with both
numerical advantages and considerably
more advanced ranged weapons despite
being a simple humanoid he was taking up
a truly insane amount of containment
resources despite his violent tendencies
Abel is still a recognizable sentient
human albeit an extremely deadly
anomalous one this led some higher-ups
at the foundation to come up with an
interesting idea what if Abel's Eternal
rage could be harnessed what if they
could use their resources to reshape
this rampaging killer into a devoted
sword of the foundation's cause after
all if he wanted worthy opponents what
could be more worthy than the anomalous
monsters that the foundation faced on a
daily basis and as long as they kept the
sarcophagus even if Abel was killed in
the line of duty he'd still be accounted
for in many ways if he could be trained
and truly brought to heal there could be
no better asset to their coming
struggles it was this logic allowing
anomalies to work for the SCP Foundation
in exchange for benefits that led to the
creation of a new groundbreaking mobile
task force MTF Omega 7 Pandora's Box
this group became the SCP foundation's
hail pass for any particularly dangerous
or potentially deadly missions they
could send in AEL along with a group of
highly trained Foundation solders
soldiers that even the ancient blade
wielding Warrior held respect for while
like their namesake Pandora's Box it
would all wind up in terrible tragedy to
begin with they achieved some of the
highest mission successful results of
any mobile task force on the
foundation's payroll no task was too
challenging for them to swoop in and
crush it this was far from expected AEL
one of the most violent scps they'd ever
contain suddenly became a great asset to
their operations a vital tool in their
quest to keep the anomalous at Bay he
cleaved through Legions of chaos
Insurgency soldiers during breaches into
their secure SES he fought off wellp
paid well-trained and well-armed
Bodyguards of Marshall Carter and dark
limited during Foundation raids on their
clandestine operations he'd even gone
toe-to-toe with some of the deadliest
anomalies in containment during mass
escapes it was hard to imagine how
they'd ever lived without him of course
while Abel was happier than he'd had
been in years in his element in fact as
as a working Warrior giving varied
missions and frequent opponents there
was still something nagging at him his
thoughts were hounded by his white whale
the endless search for a truly worthy
opponent someone or something that could
really give him a run for his money
after Millennia of leaving opponents
dead in this wake nothing would bring
him more joy than meeting someone that
actually knocked him on his ass a new
bar somewhere above him to work towards
oh what a glorious day that would be
eventually the foundation started to run
into a problem they were running out of
missions to give Abel after all he
wasn't the kind of operative you could
just give any mission to his potential
for collateral damage was truly
staggering he'd neutralize the anomaly
then Slaughter everyone within 100t
range just to work off some of the
excess energy like a hand grenade he was
powerful but dangerously imprecise if
they ran out of high priority missions
what were they supposed to do just put
AEL back in his box to gather dust until
someone else rolled around he was
getting antsy enough between missions
already that's when an unexpected member
of personnel stepped forward Dr Jack
brigh you see Dr brigh and Abel had a
history and not an altogether Pleasant
one not that anyone could really have a
pleasant history with AEL Jack was only
a junior researcher when he had his run
in carrying a seemingly worthless
Medallion dubbed SCP 963 back to its
containment Locker
that's when a wall next to him exploded
showering him with brick fragments and
dust only to reveal Abel standing behind
the new aperture before young Dr brght
even had a chance to scream Abel had
already cleaved through him leaving him
in two distinct parts that were both
very much dead at least it seemed that
way until it was revealed that Dr
Bright's Consciousness had actually been
eternally bonded with SCP
963 giving him the gift GI and curse of
immortality since then Dr BR had become
increasingly reckless in his conduct
perhaps hoping that the next time he
Fades to Black the movie that is his sad
Strange Life won't just start to roll
again of course he hasn't been lucky in
that regard yet naturally this has given
Dr brigh complex feelings about his
fellow anomalous Foundation employee so
when the call came around all the senior
researchers and site directors asking if
there were any tasks that a seemed fit
for he had one very pressing suggestion
after all it wasn't that long after Dr
brigh had been forced into a cross test
with the intention of terminating 682
which had not only been a failure but a
generally painful and exhausting
experience now perhaps it would be
Abel's turn to take his lumps he happily
put forth a suggestion claiming that
surely the foundation's new sword
wielding Golden Boy could give the
hardto destroy reptile the old College
try after all even if Abel was killed in
the process he'd just come right back it
was a situation where they really could
not lose so why not take a chance what's
the Worst That Could Happen the 05
Council found Dr Bri's pitch extremely
compelling he succeeded in every Mission
they'd given him so far so perhaps he
could carry that success into the
Herculean task of actually terminating
682 one boundlessly bloodthirsty killer
might be the only thing truly capable of
taking out another of equal magnitude
when AEL was informed of this latest
Mission he got a scary glint in his eye
they gave him warning after warning the
Beast is said to be unkillable it can
adapt to anything it's killed scores of
people and survived the attacks of
anomalies thought to be Flawless Killers
the more it was explained to him the
more Abel felt the tingling sensation
deep within was this it had he now
discovered the perfect opponent
something that would would actually
challenge him would actually put him
through his Paces yes yes yes he
accepted the mission without question
Abel would fight SCP 682 until his
breath was no longer in order to prepare
for the match SCP 682 was released into
a secure area Rocky desert-like terrain
boarded on all sides by a foundation
perimeter hundreds of meters away on all
sides they thought it best for The
Showdown to happen here after all with
combatants like Abel and 682 it was
bound to make a mess one way or another
Abel strowed with pronounced Swagger
onto the Battleground shortly afterwards
carrying perhaps the most powerful sword
he'd ever summoned it was somewhere
between a claymore and a chainsaw an
Unholy Union that gave the resulting
weapon a degree of deranged badassery
not ever seen on the battlefields of
planet Earth before carrying this thing
Abel felt like a king and he was about
to slay the most ancient and beastial of
monsters as he approached 682 and took
in the whole of it he could feel his
heart pounding with excitement in his
chest it was a huge reptilian nightmare
he could see its scales hardening into a
mighty carpes as he approached its huge
serrated fangs its bulging sinine
muscles an insane dagger likee claws oh
yes this would be the one the Beast
snarled at him as approached he just
smiled puffed out his chest and said I
have heard Tales of creatures like you
glorious beasts of scale and flesh Talon
and Fang a prowess in battle even
greater than the immense intellect
hiding behind those beastial eyes they
said your kind once Ruled the Earth from
enormous stockpiles of treasure killing
and eating all who displeased you but
you were knocked from your throne one by
one won by the great warriors who walk
this world no longer until they were no
more and you became but a mere myth even
I had thought you to be nothing but
fairy tales but yet here you stand
before me a living dragon in response to
ael's lofty speech the monster merely
grumbled and chided him claiming he was
little more than a pathetic SCP
Foundation lap dog following orders in
being manipulated it showed no respect
for Abel as a valued enemy combatant
merely another nuisance thrown at it in
a feudal attempt to finish its wretched
and seemingly eternal life AEL couldn't
take such insolence he leapt forwards
bringing down his mighty chainsaw
Claymore ready to cleave the beast in
two however what he didn't expect was
the move SCP 682 pulled next throwing
its head up against the blade of Able's
sword shredding away huge chunks of
Flesh and Bone and utterly confusing
Abel in the process for the first time
in a lifetime of intense battles Abel
found himself thinking what the hell am
I up against here the force of 682s
headbutt threw Abel off balance leaving
his stomach briefly exposed but briefly
was all SC SCP 682 needed it thundered
its massive Stony fist into Abel's gut
throwing him like a ragd doll into a
nearby rock with such a force that it
nearly shattered The Rock behind him it
was a force like he hadn't felt in years
he spat some bloody teeth and grinned
this was just what the doctor ordered he
issued a challenge to the beast in a
long dead language as it seized
violently regenerating rowing taking on
the Stony qualities of the ground around
it it looked like a vengeful living
Mountain a true Behemoth of a beast in
other words challenge accepted Abel
pulled an obscenely giant maze from the
shadows of his cloak the handle 6 ft
long with a chaos of swirling blades and
spikes a perfect weapon for slaying a
dragon like this he thought to himself
the two charged at each other full of
power and fury able swung the mace once
again shattering the creature's head and
flinging it back across the battlefield
with the sheer force of its strike the
decimated lizard clawed its way into the
ground devouring the rocks and the Earth
integrating more matter to fuel its
regeneration
but it wasn't long before Abel was upon
it again striking mercilessly giving
blows as the monster gave brutal claw
strikes in return they were ripping each
other's bodies apart Peace by piece but
Abel felt so exhilarated he could barely
even notice it was the fight of his life
a battle against a truly worthy opponent
this was Heaven Abel leaped into the air
and Unleashed a volley of deadly chakum
down onto the Beast shredding into its
reinforc flesh as the force of gravity
brought him down he pulled a mighty axe
from his cloak and bellowed A Warrior's
Roar as he brought it down splattering
into the nightmarish body of SCP
682 however this did nothing to even
slow the Beast Down it flipped over
slashing Abel with its claws when Abel
stumbled it leaped on top of him
unleashing devastating slashes and
punches onto the Fallen warrior with the
speed of a machine gun firing when it
raised its to deal with the killing blow
though AEL once again turned the tables
he produced a giant pair of mechanical
scissors from thin air and sliced off
both of SCP 682s four legs the Beast
descended with its Mighty Jaws to devour
Abel but he kicked up with freakish
strength behind his bladed boot the
sheer force of the kick flipped SCP 682
onto its back now it was ail's turn to
execute his opponent though on some
level he thought it would be an awful
shame to lose such a terrific Ric beast
from this world of cardboard still a
battle is a battle and this is how they
go he jumped on to 62 and went berserk
slashing into it relentlessly with blade
after blade pulling out a new one every
time the old one broke down from his
sheer ferocity he screamed in incoherent
battle Fury tearing slicing ripping
rening yes yes yes yes as AEL stepped
away to breathe the Beast began to
regenerate releasing a shock wave that
started to warp reality around it but
Abel wouldn't have this no he would give
this Beast No Quarter it was time to
present the true pain he was Notorious
for he pulled a long sword from his
cloak and charged taking air and
bringing it down towards
scp-682's head the Beast sensing the
Warrior's presence opened its mouth
unleashing a Chasm of horrifying teeth
within the two were on a fierce
Collision Course as the Jaws closed AEL
descended both roared in infinite rage
and blood lust both combatants fell to
the ground just twitching oh what a
glorious terrible day it had been
neither had died for good but both would
remember this incredible battle forever
when Abel awoke once more in his dark
stone coffin he did so with a smile what
a battle what a fight what a truly
honorable Pursuit after so long being
being bored and unfulfilled he found an
opponent that got his blood pumping once
more his stomach grumbled a post battle
Feast was in order now where did they
put that magic pizza box a mobile task
force makes its way through the Siberian
Forest snow covers the trees the only
light comes from the moon shining
through the branches the commander holds
up a hand signaling the team to halt in
a small clearing in front of them is the
creature they've been searching for it
appears to be part deer part human the
creature howls in pain as it rips the
skin from its body the SCP agents watch
it in horror as the creature reaches its
arm high into the air and plunges a
knife into its stomach it doubles over
in pain and stops screaming the creature
pulls the knife from its midsection and
stands upright blood splatters across
the shimmering white snow it turns
towards the mobile task force and slowly
walks towards them help me the creature
Whispers I need you to save me from
what's inside it collapses to the ground
the mobile task force secures the
creature in a containment vehicle in
preparation for further examination this
is SCP 1068 Ru shell of God when they
arrive with the creature to an
undisclosed SCP Foundation site location
Dr belov is put in charge of learning
more about the entity when SCP 1068
first awakens and its containment
chamber belov is watching from behind a
two-way mirror the creature walks up to
the mirror and examines the countless
scars and stitches that cover its body
SCP 1068 shakes its head and gingerly
runs a long finger along the freshed
wound where it stabbed itself earlier it
glances around the room as if looking
for something then turns back towards
the two-way glass what time is it it
asks Its Reflection Dr belov knows that
the creature is talking to him it may
not know who is watching him but it
knows there is someone there Dr belov
pauses for a moment what harm can it do
to tell the time he thinks belov pushes
the intercom button and speaks you've
been in there for almost 6 hours he says
into the microphone SCP 1068 looks
startled its eyes open wide as it scans
the room again you need to let me out of
here it shouts quickly or you will all
be in danger the creature starts to bang
on the glass causing Dr bov to take a
few steps back there is fear in its eyes
that terrifies the doctor belov
tentatively walks back towards the
intercom button and pushes it I'm not
sure it'd be safe to let you out quite
yet my friend why don't you tell me
what's going on there is no time SCP
1068 screams I I can feel him coming
just as it finishes the sentence as SCP
1068 stumbles backward Dr bov looks on
in horror as the creature's stomach
begins to expand as if something is
pushing on it from the inside ins side a
set of claws rips through its skin from
within warning lights begin to flash in
the observation room the temperature
around SCP 1068 has plummeted the
fluorescents in the containment chamber
start to flicker the howls of the
creature are accompanied by the
screeching of something else whoever is
trying to crawl out of SCP 1068 is
fighting hard to complete their task SCP
1068 swings the knife tied around its
wrist into its hand it begins stabbing
at whatever is trying to to burst out of
it causing blood and skin to be thrown
across the room the creature opens its
mouth and lets out a cry of pain this
goes on for several minutes before
whatever is inside SCP 1068 Retreats
back to where it came from SCP 1068
stands in the room panting it opens the
Satchel at its waist and pulls out a
bone needle and string it meticulously
begins to sew up the wounds from the
knife Dr bov watches Panic fills him as
he slams the intercom button what the
hell was that he asks that my dear
friend was my brother with those words
hanging in the air Dr belov furiously JS
down notes he needs to learn more belov
runs out of the observation room and
grabs two SCP agents to accompany him
into the Chamber of SCP 1068 he needs to
examine the creature and find out what
is going on within it when Dr belov and
the two agents enter the room SCP 1068
shows no signs of aggression although
the creature has has a masculine voice
its chest and other human parts seem to
be female its entire body is covered in
stitched up wounds however Dr belov can
see into one of the fresh punctures that
SC SCP 1068 made to itself the creature
looks at him and shakes its head you
have no idea how much danger you are in
it says we want to help you my name is
Dr belov and I work for the SCP
Foundation can I examine that wound SCP
1068 looks at the doctor considering his
question I have nothing to hide but be
aware you might not like what you see Dr
belov nods his head he holds up a
flashlight and shines it into a SCP 1068
wound what he sees gives him paw there
are no bones organs or muscles of any
type under the creature's skin the space
inside the body seems to be infinite
Perhaps it is a deep void to another
dimension belov thinks as he gets closer
to the wound he can feel a cold breeze
leaving SCP 1068 body do you mind belov
asks while holding up a thermometer the
creature shrugs indifferently belov
tries to take the temperature just
beneath the creature's skin but it is so
cold that it causes the mercury in the
thermometer to freeze the doctor
furiously writes notes into his log as
CP 1068 finishes stitching up its wounds
the creature sits back in its chair I'm
sure you have some questions let me
start by introducing myself I am I Neil
I come from an ancient tribe that
inhabited the are where you found me
many moons ago so you've been around for
a while belov asks that is correct I
lived with my seven brothers and a small
tribe of humans deep in the Siberian
Arctic my brothers and I were wiser and
more skilled than anyone else in the
tribe we eventually became deities to
them I was the patron saint of
seamstresses and a warming shoulder for
the people unfortunately not all of my
brothers were kind I think I see where
this is going says Dr belov in my
experience there is always one who
betrays the rest when it comes to beings
with special powers you may be more
right than you know says I Neil shaking
his head for a long time there was peace
and Harmony but then the great grief
happened my brother whom I will not
speak the name of was the master of the
hunt he believed that since he provided
life sustaining sustenance for everyone
he should be the ruler of the tribe I
was the closest to this brother so he
asked me to join him as his second in
command I refused I assume that probably
didn't make him too happy says spov no
it did not he was Furious and
slaughtered everyone in the tribe
including the wom and children then he
began to kill his own Brothers he
butchered our whole family and then
eventually came for me too I could not
match his combat skills but I had a plan
we battled for many nights I waited for
the perfect opportunity and when my
brother lunged at me in blind rage and
frustration I knew it was the moment I
was waiting for I ripped open my stomach
and he fell into the void I think I'm
going to be sick gags pelov are you
telling me that thing inside you is your
brother that's exactly what I'm saying s
i Neil how long has it been in you asks
bov too long that is why I have sought
the help of the SCP Foundation my
brother cannot Escape otherwise the
whole world will be doomed Dr belov
leans back in his chair and whistles he
can't believe what he is hearing but at
the same time this wouldn't be the
craziest thing he has witnessed at the
foundation now you must leave the room
says I Neil it's almost time for my
brother to try and escape again it
happens every 6 hours and if I do not
stop him he will destroy us all Dr bov
and the Agents leave the room once the
doors closed IAL begins to scream he
looks down at his stomach as his brother
rips through his insides an audio
recorder in the room picks up a
conversation between iil and his brother
as they battle they are talking in their
native language several days later Dr
belov retrieves the audio and sends the
recording to the Linguistics Department
to be decoded for several days Dr bov
watches IAL battle his brother every 6
hours the brother rips through the
stomach lining of SCP 1068 with its
claws iil stabs him using his knife and
after the bloody battle is over iil sews
himself up and rests until the next
attempted Escape Dr belov sits in the
observation room flipping through his
notes when he comes across a report from
the Linguistics Department he had
forgotten all about the recording but he
reads the translation his heart sinks in
s what in the name of God he says out
loud the conversation that was recorded
during the battle didn't make any sense
a muffled voice could be heard saying
think it over fool because of your
selfishness we will all die the cycle
must not be broken let me be
reborn this was clearly the pleading of
I Neil's brother but it is the next
words that truly terrify Dr belov they
believe your lies isn't that enough for
you the next sounds that the recorder
picked up were the stabbing of Flesh and
screams of pain Dr belov shakes his head
so I Neil is lying about something belov
thinks could he be evil perhaps the
characters in his story were switched
what if iil was the one who slaughtered
before he can finish his thought there
is a loud crash as the two-way mirror
shatters standing in the opening is SCP
1068 his eyes have changed now they are
filled with evil oh doctor I'm sorry it
has come to this but I can't let you
live when you are so close to the truth
says I kneil the creature steps through
the opening into the observation room Dr
bov screams as the knife plunges into
his stomach now watch SCP 2273 major
Alexi batro SCP animation or check out
SCP 610 the flesh that hates SCP
animation